Neo4j is a powerful graph database that enables organizations to model, store, and analyze
complex relationships between data points.
Its intuitive, graph-based structure offers a flexible and efficient solution for diverse
applications, making it a leading choice for managing connected data.
This course is taught by FreeCoCamp team members Farhan Chaudhary and Gavin Lon.
First, you will learn about Neo4j and graph database management systems, as well as how
you can benefit from incorporating them into your applications.
Next, you will learn how to use a Neo4j graph database management system as the backend
storage for a real-world application created with Java and Spring Boot.
Finally, you will learn how to create a front-end with React to interact with the data stored
with Neo4j.
Neo4j provided a grant to make this course possible.
So let's get started.
Hi and welcome.
I'm Gavin Lon.
So, I finally got my FreeCoCamp t-shirt.
I traveled all the way from the east coast of South Africa to Amsterdam and met the founder
of FreeCoCamp, Quincy Larson, and he gave me my own FreeCoCamp t-shirt.
Really great.
So the point of the trip was to meet Quincy and some of the core team members of FreeCoCamp.
In person.
It was about team building and solidifying relationships between coworkers.
The key concept in this course is, in fact, relationships.
Relationships between data.
The relationships could be between people, between car parts, between a t-shirt and a
human being.
So relationships between homogenous data or lack data, for example, between human beings,
or relationships between heterogenous data or different types of data.
These relationships can be very effectively represented within a graph database management
system.
Neo4j is a graph database management system.
In this part of the course, I want to present to you a brief overview highlighting the significance
of a graph database management system.
Before we look at Neo4j, let's contextualize the significance of a graph database management
system by looking at some of the other popular types of database management systems commonly
used today.
So let's look at three other commonly used types of database management systems before
we discuss the graph database management system and why we would want to use a graph database
management system in our applications.
The most well-known used database management system type is a relational database management
system.
The relational database management systems are SQL Server, Postgres, and MySQL.
In this type of database, tables represent entities.
For example, a table named employee contains rows of data.
Each row of data is divided into columns or fields containing employee information.
For example, the name field contains the employee name.
The age field contains the employee's age, etc.
Another data entity could be implemented in a table named department.
Each row in the department's table denotes an individual department.
For example, one row stores information for the human resources department and another
row stores information for the finance department.
These data entities or database tables within a relational database can be explicitly related
to one another within the relational database management system.
For example, an entity may have a one-to-one relationship with another entity.
So say employees and the cars they drive, a specific employee is related to a specific
car, one employee to one car.
So for example, the employee entity in this case has a one-to-one relationship with the
car entity.
Two database tables can have a many-to-many relationship.
For example, an employee could be a member of multiple teams.
And each team can contain multiple employees.
So this means an employee can be a member of more than one team, and each team can have
many employees.
So in this scenario, the employee entity has a many-to-many relationship with the team
entity.
A database entity can have a one-to-many relationship with another database entity.
For example, the department table has a one-to-many relationship with the employee table, meaning
each department can contain one or many employees, and an employee can only be a member of one
department at a given time.
So this one-to-many relationship can be established within the relational database management system
through an appropriate schema design.
A database schema defines how data is organized within a relational database, which includes
constraints such as table names, fields, data types, and the relationships between the relevant
entities.
So for example, the one-to-many relationship between the department table and the employee
table can be implemented by including a primary key, which is a unique identifier for a row
of data in the department table, and a foreign key field within the employee table, which
relates to the primary key value within the department table.
The main advantages of a relational database design is that it helps facilitate data integrity,
so the data is not easily corrupted.
As well as reduces data redundancy, storage for repeated values are reduced.
For example, if you stored department data within the employee table, you can see here,
the department short name field and long name field values are repeated across rows in the
employee table, whereas separating the data into an employee table and a department table
means these values are not repeated, resulting in saving storage space.
As the data scales, this storage saving can be quite significant.
A technique known as normalization is employed to design a relational database.
I won't go into the details of normalization here, but please look up normalization, which
is a key concept in relational database design.
So the technique of normalization can increase data integrity, minimizing data corruption
and also significantly reducing data redundancy, i.e. unnecessarily storing values repeatedly.
The downside to relational databases is the speed of retrieving data when multiple joins
or deep joins between entities are necessary.
For example, if you want to retrieve analytical data that summarizes data from multiple entities,
a normalized database design can cause the retrieval of such data to be a slow process.
So the way to speed up data retrieval can be to use a schema-less database management
system like, for example, MongoDB.
This is a document-based database management system.
The fact that the database design is not bound by a schema like with a relational database
management system can result in increased speed of data retrieval as well as allow for
better design flexibility.
So you can see that each of these database management systems have their purpose and
advantages.
Another type of database management system may use a name-value pair storage structure
like, for example, Redis.
This database management system is great for caching frequently retrieved data and therefore
can help speed up a system.
So we have briefly looked at three common types of database management systems.
Relational database management systems like, for example, SQL Server or Postgres, schema-less
database management systems like, for example, MongoDB, and name-value pair database management
systems like Redis.
So let's look at the significance of a graph database management system.
Neo4j is a graph database management system.
This type of database management system is based on the graph data structure.
All of these social media platforms use graph databases, Twitter, Facebook, and Instagram.
As we all know, these platforms have millions of users.
A relational database management system would not be ideal as the only storage facility
for such data.
Because of the way the data is structured would mean multiple joints between entities
would need to be made.
When relevance data is retrieved, which would drastically slow down the data retrieval process
ultimately causing a poor UX user experience because the whole system is slowed down by
these joints that need to be made between data.
So note that when designing a particular system like a social media platform, you could incorporate
both a graph database management system and a relational database management system into
your overall system design.
This type of solution could combine the enforced data integrity inherent in relational database
management systems with the complex relationships between data entities or nodes that can be
facilitated using a graph database management system.
For example, the master database could be a relational database where data integrity
and data redundancy concerns are addressed by the inherent benefits that we have discussed
regarding a relational database management system.
A graph database management system that is appropriately synchronized with the relevant
relational database management system can be leveraged to increase the retrieval speed
of data that, for example, has complex relationships.
If data that requires complex relationships was retrieved directly from the relational
database management system, the joints required when retrieving the relevant data could significantly
slow down the system and ultimately result in a very poor UX user experience.
So by including a graph database management system in the overall system where it sits
on top of the relational database management system, as it were, and is used to speed up
the retrieval of data with complex relationships, this could significantly speed up the data
retrieval process resulting in a far better UX user experience.
So this sort of system would require that the data stored in the relevant graph database
management system and the relevant relational database management system be synchronized
so as to ensure that the data is consistent across the two disparate database management
systems.
So a system like this, when designed properly, can leverage the benefits of both types of
database management systems.
For graph-based data structures, a database management system that focuses on the facilitation
of relationships between entities or nodes is essential, and a graph database management
system provides a way to store data based on the graph data structure, which is ideal
for applications that consume data where entities have multiple relationships and complex relationships
with one another.
Think about social media platforms where you have relationships between users and posts,
likes, friendships, etc., and you have millions of people using these platforms.
A database management system is needed that appropriately facilitates the storage of data
for a large number of different types of relationships.
A graph database management system allows for relationships to be stored as data within
the graph database.
With a relational database management system, the emphasis is on the entities, and generally
the relationships between the entities are not stored in the database, but rather general
relationships are established at the design level.
For example, you can see by the foreign key field value that the employee is a member
of the HR department, but there are no details about the relationship itself between the
relevant department and employee, saved in the database.
This is something you could easily do within a graph database management system.
You could create a more detailed relationship.
You can easily save data regarding individual relationships between entities or nodes, for
example between an employee node and a department node.
So here is a whiteboard presentation that shows how the relationships between individual
employees and employees and departments could be represented within a graph database.
So here we see a node that represents a department.
This node is appropriately labeled department.
Details related to this department node can be saved to the database as properties and
related values.
So this department contains a short name property with a value of HR, and a long name property
with a value of human resources.
Here is our first employee node.
This node is appropriately labeled employee.
The employee node contains properties and relevant values representing the employee's
name and age.
Here we see our first relationship.
This relationship explicitly shows that the employee whose name is Brad Jenkins is part
of the HR department.
This relationship is appropriately labeled member of.
So you can see that this is a very human readable representation of data.
The fact that this employee is a member of the HR department is clear through appropriate
labeling and properties.
So Brad Jenkins is a member of the HR department.
We are able to add properties to the relationships themselves.
So the member of relationship has a join date property as well as an employee type property.
You can see by this data when this employee joined the department and that this employee
has a permanent role and is not for example a contractor.
Here we have the second employee node who has the name Jenny Lane.
Jenny is also a member of the HR department.
We can save relationships between employees within our graph database.
So Jenny works with Brad.
We can also create another works with relationship in the opposite direction where Brad works
with Jenny.
So you can see that we have a one department to many employees relationship just like what
was shown earlier in the relational database but a graph database is far more flexible
in terms of design when establishing relationships between data points or nodes.
Not only can the entities contain associated data but the relationships themselves can
also contain data i.e. through properties and associated values.
So we could create even more complex relationships between nodes.
For example a chain of command hierarchical structure related to our employee nodes.
So here is an example of this where employee James Stokes reports to another employee Jenny
Lane.
This is just a simple example and of course this hierarchical data structure could become
far more complex.
So this presentation was only intended to give you a basic idea of how much more flexible
the design of relationships between entities can be within a graph database and how complex
relationships between entities can be easily implemented within a graph database.
I want to show you a brief demonstration of using Cypher to query a graph database and
to do this I'll firstly create a Neo4j database on my local machine.
I'll use my Mac platform to demonstrate this.
I'll contrast using Cypher and Neo4j with using SQL in the SQL Server database which
of course is a relational database management system.
Firstly what is Cypher?
Cypher can be likened to SQL or Structured Query Language.
Cypher is a text-based declarative language used for querying a Neo4j database.
What is meant by a declarative language?
A declarative language is a high level language that describes what a computation should perform.
These languages must follow strict semantic rules, must be structured in a particular
way.
In order to be valid and for desired results to be returned from the relevant database
management system, for example using SQL in order to bring back all employee records from
the employee table, you would appropriately execute the following SQL code.
This SQL statement simply returns all rows and all columns from the employee table.
Using Cypher if you wanted to return all employee data, you would use a query like this.
This query would return all employee nodes and relevant relationships.
Although when comparing these two query languages, they are of course semantically different,
but principally they are the same in that the relevant declarative text-based code is
parsed by the appropriate database management system converted into appropriate instructions
that are executed under the hood as it were.
The relevant results are then returned from the relevant database.
I'd like to demonstrate using Cypher within a Neo4j database.
I'll contrast executing Cypher against the Neo4j database with executing similar queries
against a similar database implemented in a SQL Server database.
You don't need to follow along with this part of the course, but of course you can if you
want to.
So if you want to follow along, you can install Neo4j on your Mac or Windows platforms by
following the instructions at this URL.
I have already installed Neo4j on my Mac platform.
If you want to install a free version of SQL Server, please navigate to this URL.
But as discussed, this part of the course is only intended to be an overview and not
a detailed explanation, so it's not necessary to follow along with this part of the course.
I've created these scripts on GitHub for this part of the demonstration, so I'm going to
copy this script from GitHub and run it in Neo4j to generate my Neo4j graph database.
So within Neo4j Desktop, let's create a new project.
I'm going to call this project Sample Project.
Then let's create a new database.
I'm going to name my Neo4j Database Company DB.
Let's give our database a password.
Then let's press the Create button.
And now we need to start the database, so let's press the Start button to do this.
Then to execute our Cypher queries, let's click this Open button and open the appropriate
window from which we can execute our Cypher queries.
So the first thing we need to do is copy the code for creating our graph database.
So let's navigate to this appropriate GitHub URL.
Let's copy this code from GitHub and appropriately paste the code within the window that we can
use to run our queries through Neo4j Desktop.
Great.
And let's click the Play button to create our graph database.
Excellent.
And we are presented with appropriate status information, telling us that our graph database
has been created successfully.
I'm going to run this script within SQL Server to generate a similar database, the difference
of course being that this database is designed as a relational database.
So let's appropriately copy this SQL code from GitHub.
Let's launch SQL Server Management Studio.
Let's run our SQL code to create our database.
I've already created a database named the CompanyDB test.
So I'm going to create a new database named the CompanyDB test2.
Then I need to change the relevant SQL script to point to the new database that I've just
created.
So let's press the Play button to run the script and create our database tables and
relevant data.
Great.
So I'm going to run a few queries so that you can get a basic understanding of the differences
and similarities regarding Cypher and SQL.
So let's run this query against the Neo4j database.
Great.
This query brings back all the employee nodes and relevant relationships.
In order to retrieve all employee data from within the relevant SQL Server database, you
could run a SQL query like this.
And let's say we wanted to retrieve particular data about a particular employee.
So you could run this Cypher query like this.
Within the SQL Server database, you could run a SQL query like this.
Okay, so now the next query I'd like to run is a little bit more interesting.
So in both these two databases, we have expressed a hierarchical relationship between employees.
In the Neo4j database, this is implemented through the report to relationship established
between employees.
In the SQL Server database, the same hierarchical relationship between employees is expressed
but through the use of what's known as a self-joining table.
So in this case, the employee table joins to itself through the relationship between
the report to ID field and the ID field, which stores each employee's ID.
So in the employee table, the hierarchical relationship between employees is established
through the use of the report to ID field, which stores the employee ID of the relevant
employee's immediate boss, if you like.
So employee Brad Jenkins is at the bottom of the hierarchy, as it were.
So if you wanted to query the SQL database to get the chain of command from Brad Jenkins
to the top of the hierarchy, you need to run a query like this.
As you can see, this query is really difficult to understand at first glance, and recursion
is used to get the desired results.
A graph database is far easier to understand in terms of retrieving such tree data structures
from the relevance database.
So to use cipher code to retrieve the relevant hierarchical data, starting with an employee
at the bottom of the hierarchy, Brad Jenkins, you would run cipher code like this against
this particular database.
Great.
Okay, so I hope this part of the course has given you at least a basic understanding of
a graph database management system, and how you can benefit from incorporating a graph
database management system into your applications.
Farhan will now go into more detail, where he'll use a Neo4j graph database management
system as the backend storage facility for the server-side part of a real-world web-based
application.
I will then follow Farhan and create the front-end code for this application using React.
Hello everyone, welcome to this course.
I am Farhan Hassan Choudhury, one of the instructors, and I will walk you through the entire process
of working with a Neo4j database, as well as the development of an API powered by Springboot
Framework.
Now, at this point of the course, I will show you how you can create a new account for the
Neo4j Aura cloud database service, how to create a new database, and run some simple
queries.
Now, keep in mind that this is not going to be an exhaustive list of all the commands
and queries that you can run inside a Neo4j database.
What I am going to do is I will show you how you can create a node, how you can create
relationships, how you can delete a node, update a node, and some other basic grad operations.
In a word, I will teach you whatever is necessary to create the API.
Now, to begin with, we will navigate to Neo4j's website.
I will leave the link in the description so you can follow along.
And once you are here, you will use the Get Started Free button to create a new account.
Now start free.
And if you wish, you can sign up for a new account using your email address, but what
I am going to do is I will just use my Google account to log in.
Now, I have successfully logged into Neo4j Aura, and I hope you have done that too.
So this is the dashboard that they give us.
You can see there are the instances that we are going to create.
Now, to create a new instance of a database, just click on the New Instance button, and
it will give you a free template.
Like if you are a beginner, you can start here, and it will give you some data to start
with.
What we are going to pick is an empty instance, because I want to show you how you can create
new nodes, relationships, labels, and things like that.
So we will hit Create, then they will generate a password for us.
Now you can copy that password using this button, or even better, you can use this Download
button to download all the credentials as a text format.
I am not going to do that yet, but I will show you later on how that works out.
So once you have copied the credentials, click on Confirm.
I have copied or downloaded the above credentials so that they will know that you have the credentials,
because you cannot get it once you have gone past this step.
Now we will do Continue.
Now the creation process of a new instance is a bit long.
It can take around a minute or so.
So what I am going to do is I am going to pause the recording and come back once the
instance has been created.
So it looks like that the database has been created.
It's running on GCP or Google Cloud Platform, and since I am from Asia, I am from Bangladesh,
the region closest to me was Singapore.
Now we also have a connection URI.
Now to connect to this instance, all you have to do is click on the open button.
But before that, just in case you want to rename your instance, you can go here and
you can use rename.
I am not going to do that though, so I will just open it and they will ask for a password.
So I will just paste in my password and the database user will be Neo4j.
You don't have to change any of these things, just click connect.
Now once you have landed on your workspace, you will see that there are no nodes and relationships
whatsoever.
But I would like to show you how you can create new nodes, how you can create new relationships
between them, how you can update a node.
Now the Cypher query language is really expressive and this is really easy to learn if you have
experience with some other query languages like SQL.
But even if you do not have any experience with that, Cypher is not that hard to learn.
The Cypher documentation is an excellent piece of resource.
They also have a cheat sheet.
Now I will leave a link to this cheat sheet in the description of this video.
You can visit these and you can essentially learn about how to read all the nodes in a
database using the match clause or how to filter them using where return variables.
And under write queries, you can also learn about creating new nodes, labels and relationships.
Set for updating them, delete and remove for getting rid of nodes and labels and things
like that.
So let's suggest that you bookmark this Cypher cheat sheet in your browser so that you can
refer back to it whenever you need and also the documentation.
Now I will go back to our workspace and I will start creating a bunch of node and I
will explain how you can do that as well.
So let's switch back to our workspace.
And the first thing that we want to do is we want to create a new node.
So we will begin with the create clause and a set of parentheses.
Then we will put a colon here and we will write the label of the node.
So a node is an independent or a single entity inside your database and it has to be labeled
something.
For example, if we create a node in our database with the name Farhan Hassan Choudhury, it
would be hard to say what this node represents.
Does it represent a user?
Does it represent someone's pet cat?
What is it?
So we are labeling our node with the label user.
And then we will put some properties here.
The first thing I want to put is a name for this user.
So Farhan name colon Farhan Singh Choudhury, then I will put a comma.
The next is a username.
This is a unique username and we will use it to uniquely identify every single user.
So we will say username is just Farhan.
And that's all I am going to put here.
Now I will execute the command using the play button.
And looks like we have a new label here.
And if I click on this, it will return everything under this label to us.
Now instead of clicking on this label, we can also use the match class.
So we will say match.
And we want to match for all the nodes in our database.
We will say return all the nodes.
Now this is just a variable by the way.
If you want to call it nodes, nodes, you can do that as well.
Just make sure you are not using any of the reserved keywords.
For example, if I remove the S here, you will see it becomes red, which means it's a keyword.
Like match and return, we cannot use it.
So I will change it back to nodes.
I will run the query.
And as you can see, we have all our nodes here.
Now let's go ahead and create two more users.
So I will say create.
And this time I want to actually create multiple users with a single create call.
So I will keep pressing shift and press enter to come on the next line.
I will start a set of parentheses.
I will create a new user with the name John.
And his username will be just John.
Then outside of the last parentheses, I will put a comma and I will again keep pressing
shift and press enter to come to the second line.
And I will open another set of parentheses.
I will create another user and her name will be Jane and username will be just Jane.
It has to be string.
Now if I end this query with a semicolon at the end, I can just press on this play button.
And as you can see, I have successfully created two new nodes and four sets of properties.
So if I say match n for nodes and return n, I can get all the nodes in our database.
So I have for instance, I have John and I have Jane.
Now the thing is all these three nodes are of the user label.
So it would be nice to have another label on our system.
So let's go ahead and create a bunch of courses.
Now to create a course, we will use the same syntax as before and you can use your up arrow
to bring back your old queries.
And I will just make some changes to this query.
I will switch user with course in both cases.
I will replace title with C++ course and the username with identifier.
This is an unique identifier for the course, which is CPP.
And the next course we will have is title JavaScript course and we can call it JS.
Finally, we can have another course called C sharp course and its identifier will be
C sharp.
Whether I have made a mistake here, it should be identifier and not username.
So let's look at our query.
We are creating three courses with titles C++ course, JavaScript course and C sharp course.
They all have a unique identifier, CPP JS and C sharp.
So I execute this command.
Looks like I have a mistake, which is I did not put a comma at the end.
And how did I know that?
So it, as you can see Neo4j is actually telling me that there is some problem in the beginning
of the course title C sharp line, but I can see that it's totally fine.
So it's highly likely that the mistake is actually at the end of the previous line.
So that's how I thought that maybe I have missed a comma.
So I will run this query again and I have created three new nodes and I will say match
n and I will return n.
So as you can see, I have all my nodes here.
There is Jane, John and Farhan has seen chosen these are the users and C++, JavaScript and
C sharp.
These are my courses.
Now it would be nice if I could create a relationship between Jane and the C++ course, John and
JavaScript and Farhan has seen on C sharp course.
So I want to essentially enroll them in this course, but before that I would like to show
you a few variation of the match clause.
So right now when we say match n return n, it actually returns all the nodes in our database.
What if I want to only get the course nodes or the user nodes?
We can do that by defining a label after this variable like this.
So I want all the users return n as users.
You can actually do that.
If you use as, you can actually rename your variables to make them more user friendly.
So I am matching all the node of label user and I returning them as users.
I will press play.
As you can see, I am now getting only the users and not the courses.
Likewise, I can replace n with C or let's just keep it n since that's just a variable.
I am picking the course as instead of users, I will say courses.
By the way, you can press Ctrl Enter to execute your query without pressing the play button.
So right now I am getting only the courses.
But what if I only want to get one user?
For example, I only want to match for the user with username for HAN.
So I can do that.
I can say match u for user.
So I will put user then I will use the where clause.
This is used for filtering or query results.
So I will say where u.username is equals for HAN return u as for HAN.
So what I am doing essentially here is I am matching for a user type that has the username
for HAN.
I am putting it inside u and I am returning u as for HAN.
Let's run this query.
And as you can see, I am getting for HAN since you three back.
Now let's add a course to the mix.
So after I am saying u colon user, I can put a comma start another set of parentheses.
I can say C course.
So where u.username equals for HAN and C.identifier is equals CPP return u comma C.
So this time I am removing the as keyword.
And what I am doing here, I am matching for a user and a course where the username is
equals for HAN and course.identifier is equals CPP.
Finally I am returning u and C. Let's see if it works.
As you can see, we have successfully found the C++ course and the for HAN has into three
user.
Now we are actually ready to create a relationship between these two nodes.
So I will bring back my old query and instead of returning them, I want to say create because
I want to create a new relationship and I will first take the user.
So here I have the user.
Then I will put a dash, then a set of square braces and inside I will say colon enrolled
in.
This is the type of relationship this user is going to have with the course.
So what we are doing, we are matching for a user and a course where the username is
for HAN and course identifier is CPP.
Then we are creating a relationship.
What kind of relationship you say?
We are creating an outgoing relationship from the user.
And how do I know that, as you can see, there is an arrow going out from the user towards
the course.
So this is an outgoing relationship from the user.
And what is the type of this relationship?
The type is actually enrolled in.
Now we can actually save this relationship inside a variable called R.
And I can say return R.
So if I press the play button again, it just looks like I have successfully created a relationship.
So the relationship actually starts at node 1 and ends at node 4, which means that the
ID of HAN has been showed here is 1 and ID of CPP is 4.
If I go to user, you can see for HAN has been showed here has the ID 1.
And if I go to course, C++ course has the ID of 4.
Okay and the type of relationship is enrolled in, there are no properties whatsoever.
There are the element ID, start node element ID and things like that.
We do not have to worry about them.
So that's how you can create a relationship between these two nodes.
So that's how you can create relationships inside of Neo4j.
Now let's see how you can update a property of a node.
So if I want to update the name of John to John Doe and John to John Doe, I can do that.
First we have to find John in our database, so we will send match a variable u of type
user where u.username equals John.
So now we are matching for a user with the username John.
Then we want to use set, this is another clause in Neo4j cipher language.
So I will say set u.name equals John Doe.
And if I execute this query, looks like it has done its job.
So if I go back and instead of setting it, if I return u, John has now become John Doe.
We can do the same thing with Jane because why not, they are related.
Jane and we can say Jane Doe.
Okay, so I want to return Jane, return u.
There you have it.
So now you have learned how to match nodes in the database.
You have learned how to create new relationships, update values of an existing node.
Now that's pretty much all you are going to need for the API development process.
But I would like to show you one last clause from the cipher query language.
And that is the exist clause.
For example, if you ever want to check if Farhan has introduced is enrolled in the C++
course or not, you can do that using the exist clause.
So we will begin with match and what do we want to match?
We want to match for an user and we want to match for a course where u.username is equals
Farhan and c.identifier is equals cpp.
Now we have an user with the username Farhan and we also have a course with the identifier
cpp.
Next, what we want to do is we want to say return and we will call the exists function.
This is a function and that's why we have these two parentheses and inside these parentheses
we want to describe a relationship.
So the relationship we are looking for or checking for is whether user is enrolled in
the course or not.
So we will finish our query.
What we are doing, we are matching for a user with the username Farhan and we are matching
for a course with the identifier cpp.
Then we are checking whether a relationship between them of type enrolled in exists or
not.
So I will press the play button and it says true.
Now if I switch cpp for something else like JS, we have the JavaScript course and I hit
the play button, you will see I am getting false.
Now to be honest that's all you need to know to go through this entire course but Cypher
is a really excellent query language and if you have plans to learn a lot more Neo4j than
I have showed you in this course, I would suggest that you go through their documentation,
you go through their cheat sheet and you practice making your own databases, querying them in
a lot of different scenarios and learn as much as you can about this database system.
Now I am going to finish this lesson here but in the next lesson you will see me using
an initializer Cypher script to create a new database for our API and from there we will
begin working on our Java code.
In this part of the course, we are finally going to start working on our Spring Boot
API but before that we need to set a few things up.
First thing first, go back to your Neo4j Aura database dashboard and delete any old instances
that you may have created.
While working with the API, we want to start with a clean slate so that we can be sure
of the fact that some old data will not mess up our API.
To delete an old instance, you can use the delete button here and then you will have
to write the name of the instance.
It's just to make sure that you are in your right senses and you are not sleeping or anything.
Click on the Destroy button and wait until the instance is being destroyed.
Now to create a new instance, use the New Instance button, choose Empty Instance and
click on the Create button.
Make sure you download the credentials file because we are going to need it later on and
also let them know that you have downloaded the credential file by clicking on this check
box.
Click on Continue.
Now creating a new instance may take a few minutes, so what I am going to do is I am
just going to speed up the process in this video so that you don't have to wait around
for long.
Once the instance has been created, click the Open button, accept their terms and conditions
and when they ask for the password, open up the credentials file you just downloaded.
Just highlight the password here, copy it and paste it on the empty password field.
Click on Connect and we have successfully connected to our new instance.
Now as you can see, this instance is completely empty but we will need some data to work on
our API.
For that, I have already created an initializer script that you can use to initialize the
database.
For that, go to the code repository on GitHub, I will leave the link on the description below.
Then go inside the data folder, you will find a file called initializer.cypher.
Open up this file and go to Raw, highlight all the lines and copy with Ctrl C. Then go
back to your RRDB dashboard, paste the code that you just copied and then press the play
button to execute the code.
As you can see, the code has successfully created some nodes, relationships and property
keys.
Now the first node that I would like to show you is the user node.
Now this represents all the users in our database.
For example, if we open up John Price, you can see that it has an ID, it has a name John
Price, it has an encrypted password hash, it has roles and it has username.
Now the significance of each of these properties will become more clear as you start working
on the API.
For now, just keep in mind that all these properties are important for our application.
Next up, we have course.
This represents each of the courses that will be available on our system.
So if I click on the Blazor Shopping Cart course, you can see that it has an ID of 10.
It has a string identifier that we are going to use to uniquely identify this course.
It has the name of the teacher and a title.
Now you may argue that we can use the ID to uniquely identify this course while that's
correct.
I prefer using some other unique string or identifier to identify my course or entities.
I just do not like to rely on the auto-generated ID fields in any database at all.
Finally, we have the lessons.
These are the individual lessons that belongs to some course.
For example, if we click on the Blazor WebAssembly and WebAPI on.NET 6 lesson, you can see it
has an identifier just like the courses.
It has a title and it also has an ID.
Now this lessons here has a belongs to relationship with the courses, which means each of these
lessons belongs to a certain course.
For example, if I zoom in on the Blazor course, as you can see, all these four lessons belongs
to the Blazor Shopping Cart course.
Finally, there is the enrolled in relationship, which is between the individual users and
courses.
So for example, John W here is enrolled in the Blazor Shopping Cart course.
Now that we are done with our database, we can finally start working with our API.
For that, you will need JDK pre-installed on your computer.
Now you can download the JDK from Oracle's website.
I am going to use JDK 17 since that's the latest long-term support release.
But you can also go with JDK 20, it's totally up to you.
One more thing for those who are watching this course on Linux, it's totally fine to
use any of the open JDK builds.
For example, I myself am using the Microsoft build of open JDK instead of Oracle's official
build, and given the complexity of our API, it's not going to make any change or it will
not break anything whatsoever.
So feel free to use any open JDK build that you like.
You will also need a good IDE to make your programming process more fun.
I'm going to use IntelliJ IDEA Ultimate here.
I have a student license, so I'm going to use that.
But if you want, you can also use the community edition.
To be honest, if you look at the feature comparison here, most of the essentials are available
under the community edition.
We do not need the HTTP client thing since we are going to use a third-party client anyway.
We do not need database tools or SQL or any of these things for this project at least.
Finally, we need to initialize our project.
For that, we are of course going to use the Spring Initializer.
Now I will leave the link to Spring Initializer down in the description.
So once you have navigated to this page, we will make some choices here and we will generate
our project boilerplate.
First, make sure that you are picking Maven under project here.
You can also use Gradle if you have previous experience with the tool, but I'm just going
to pick Maven.
The language will remain Java.
For the Spring Boot version, I'm going to use 3.1.0 since that's the latest at the time
of recording.
But if some other version comes out later on while you are watching this course, feel
free to use that.
Just do not pick any of the snapshots.
Pick unstable release.
Now under group, you will have to type or you should type some domain in reverse order.
For example, my own domain is Farhan.dev, so I will just type in dev.farhan.
Then artifact is just the project name.
So I'm going to call it Spring Boot Neo4j.
You may call it anything that you like.
I will also put a sensible description like a simple API powered by Neo4j.
Finally, make sure that you are picking the correct Java version from down here.
I'm going to pick 17 since that's what I have installed on my computer.
But if you have installed 20, make sure that you are switching to 20.
For packaging format, we will go with jar since that a lot widely used than wire format.
So let's not change that.
Now the most important part, adding dependencies.
Now this is needless to say that we will need a number of different dependencies for our
project.
But for starters, I will just pick Spring Web and the dev tools.
Now you may think that why not pick the Neo4j dependencies while we are here?
Well, I could have picked them, but one thing that I have noticed in the past is that many
people face difficulties while they try to add new dependencies to a project that they
have already initialized.
So I thought why not start the project with just the bare bones, you know, essential dependencies
only and then as we go forward, we will keep adding new dependencies to our project.
That way it will represent a much more realistic development workflow and it will also teach
you how you can search for new dependencies and add them on the flag.
So take a good look at all the choices you have made.
And once you are happy with them, click on generate.
It will download a little zip file to your computer that contains all the project file.
So I'm going to just open up the zip file using no Windows Explorer or WinRAR or whatever
you like, copy the project folder, go to a place where you usually put your codes in.
I usually put them in individual directories.
So I'm going to paste it here.
And once I have done that, I will just open up my IDE, which is IntelliJ IDEA.
I will open up my project, input Neo4j, okay, yes, we trust the project.
And once you have opened the project for first time, I would say give it some time to cache
all your dependencies, read the source files and things like that so the IDE knows about
your project and it can help you along the way.
Hello everyone, I'm your instructor Farhan, but I'm from future.
Now in the next lessons, you may see a little problem with the video in some cases when
I'm trying to create a new class or maybe a new package, you may see that this menu
is not showing up.
Now this is because my recorder was only recording one window in my computer, so all the sub
menus were invisible.
So whenever you see me creating a new package, all you have to do is right click on your
main package, go to new and then package.
Likewise, when I'm creating a new class, you have to pick Java class from here and you
can switch between interfaces and classes right from this menu.
Another thing that didn't work in my previous recording was the code generation thing.
So whenever you are creating a new model, you can use the alt insert key combination,
sorry, inside that class of course, let's get rid of the constructor and you can use
alt insert and you can then generate a constructor, you can generate getters and setters and equals
and hash code, two strings and all those boilerplate methods.
So what I did in those videos is I picked constructor and then I just ignored all these
properties since you are trying to create an empty constructor and then press OK.
So a good chunk of the course, if you see all these sub menus are invisible, just don't
be alarmed, it was some problem with my recorder, everything should work as is in your computer.
Now back to the past.
As you can see, IntelliJ idea has finally finished resolving all the dependencies in
my project, so I am finally ready to write some code.
Now before we start writing Java code, I'd like to address something really important.
I hope that you remember back when we are generating our project, we didn't add all
the dependencies to our project because I wanted to show you how you can manually add
dependencies later on.
So this is the time we do that.
First open up your pom.xml and find this dependencies part.
Like that, you can see that there are three dependencies already described.
You may recognize the Spring Boot starter web and Spring Boot dev tools dependencies
from a few moments ago when we added them to our project.
But there is also another thing called Spring Boot starter test.
Now this is for testing our code and in this course we are not going to talk about that.
Now the first dependency that we need to add to our project is called the Spring Boot starter
data Neo4j and the group ID will be org.springframework.boot.
Now IntelliJ idea is being really generous here and helping us out with writing the dependencies,
but I suggest that you make sure that you are typing them out correctly because if you
make a typo or write wrong name then you may end up not getting a dependency or even worse
getting the wrong dependency.
Now the second dependency that we need is called the Neo4j Java driver and the group
is org.neo4j.driver.
Now whenever you add or remove a dependency from your pom.xml file you have to right click
on the pom.xml file, find maven and reload project.
Depending on how many dependencies you have added or removed from your project the resolving
process may take a while but in my case it has finished in a flash.
Now I will close the pom.xml file and start creating the packages that we will need.
Now inside our main package def.faham.springboot.neo4j it may be something else in your case but inside
our main package we will create four new packages.
The first one will be called config then we will create another package called models
then we will have the repositories then we will have the services and our controllers.
Now these are not the only packages that we are going to need we will also need some packages
to hold our query results, our data transfer objects, our requests and things like that
but we will work on them later.
For now these are the ones that we need.
Now once you have all the package ready to go let's create the model for our first node
which in this case will be the course.
So let's create a new java class and call it course then inside we will define all the
necessary properties of this class.
So the first one is an id and it has to be of type long then we will have private string
identifier which we used uniquely identifier our courses then private string title and
private string teacher then we will create a constructor now you may write the constructor
by hand but inside IntelliJ you can just press on alt and then insert to bring up this nice
generate menu from here you can select constructor and for our constructor we will not select
any of the properties.
Now for spring data Neo4j this is one of the requirements that you create an empty constructor
inside your model classes so this is what we are going to do then we will say alt insert
and we will select getters and setters and we will highlight identifier title and teacher
we will not highlight id and why you will understand in a bit click OK and now we have
all the getters and setters for our private properties.
Now creating a class like this will not suffice we will also have to annotate this class with
a node annotation this way spring boot will know that this class is actually a Neo4j node
and has to be managed by the dependency injection system then inside the class we will also
annotate the id with two separate annotations the first one has to be the id annotation
to let a spring boot know that this is the id for the node and then we will say generated
value which means we want this value to be automatically generated and we do not want
to write it by hand.
Now since this id is an automatically generated value we do not need a setter for it and since
we are not going to use this to uniquely identify our course we are going to use this string
identifier instead we can just get rid of the getter as well.
So now that we have a course class the next thing to create is a repository so let's go
inside the repositories package go to new java class and we will call this course repository
and it has to be an interface by the way once you have created the interface it is going
to extend the Neo4j repository interface which comes with our dependency and this is a generic
and inside we will write the name of the class that we are working with which is course and
we will also write the data type of the id of this course so in our case it will be lot.
Now this way of creating a new repository is nothing unique to Neo4j actually if you
have experience with Spring Boot in the past and you have worked with databases like MongoDB
or MySQL you may have created interfaces like this.
Now let's close our repository and model and let's go inside our service we will create
another java class called course service and we will have to annotate this class with the
service annotation and inside this class we will need a reference to our course repository
so we will say private final course repository course repository you can name it anything
and then we will generate a new constructor where we will take the repository now that's
it now since we have annotated this service class with the service annotation and also
the repository extends the base Neo4j repository this will be automatically injected into our
class.
Now inside here we will create another public method we will say public and it is going
to return a list of courses get all courses you can name it anything by the way then we
will say return course repository dot find all that's it finally we will create a controller
by the way if you think that I'm going to fast just be patient once I have created the
model repository service and controller for the course I will explain the entire workflow
or the architecture of the application what I am planning to do and what you should do
in any of your Spring Boot applications.
So finally I will create a controller new java class and it will be called course controller
now I need to annotate this class with the rest controller annotation so Spring Boot knows
that this is actually a rest controller and this is going to describe a few endpoints
then I will say request mapping this another annotation and I will describe the general
endpoint so I will say slash API slash v1 slash courses excellent now inside this public
class I will create a private reference to our service class so I will say private final
course service course service then I will generate my constructor and I will create
my first method which will be public and it will return our response entity yes response
entity of type list course I will explain what it is in a bit just just hold on for
a little longer and I will call my method course index you can call it anything this
is just going to list out all the courses in our application and then we will say return
new response entity and inside here I will call course service dot get all courses then
comma HTTP status dot ok and with a semicolon then I will also have to annotate this class
with a get mapping call and this let's let's take a final look at our application and make
sure that the code is working fine yeah that that looks ok now we have a model that describes
the course node in our database and as I have said few times already in our database the
courses have an ID which is an auto generated field we have a string identifier a title
and teacher then we will need an empty constructor for all our models then we have some getters
and setters to work with this model we create a repository interface which in turn extends
the Neo4j repository interface now what is this interface actually to see what this contains
we can press on the control button and then click on this repository once you are inside
the source code you can see it gives us a few useful methods and one of them is find
all so whenever I am going to call find all in this repository it will actually return
all the courses in our database in a list format as you can see it says list t there
is also find all by ID there is also find all with a sort functionality so we can sort
the courses so this is what a repository supports there is also a save all method but let's
ignore that for now now since we have a repository we can use it inside a service you do not
want to use your repositories inside a controller directly because that's not a good thing to
do you should always create a service layer that talks to the repositories and use that
service inside your controller layer always remember that controllers should be responsible
for taking and giving back data they should not worry themselves about the underlying
architecture of your database or your models or anything like that so in this case we have
a service class that makes a reference to our course repository and we have a single method
that gets all the courses for us one thing that I'd like to mention here that you may have seen
the auto wired annotation that comes with the spring boot and maybe instead of creating a
constructor like this I could have just annotated this field with auto wired but in some cases
that's not the best thing to do now since we have our service we will go to our controller
that describes a single endpoint which is api slash v1 slash courses inside this method we
are just returning a new response entity this is one of the classes that comes with spring boot
and you can use it to return a response to the user and this response entity thing takes two
things one is body and the other is the status code now for body we are giving it the list of
the course since it's a response entity of type list course and for status code maybe we have
written 200 by by hand but instead of using some magic number what we are doing here we are using
the value of ok inside HTTP status this is actually an enum this enum here actually describes a lot
of other status codes as you can see it has continue it has switching protocol processing
checkpoint ok created accepted we are going to use created very soon no content and a lot of
other things we are going to make use of this enumerator a lot in our application
so technically our application is ready to run and give us the list of courses but we have to
make one final adjuster and that is we have to let the application know about our database that
we have created earlier for that we will need another dependency now the dependency that we
need is called spring dot env so we will say dependency and inside artifact id we will write
spring dot env and inside group id we will say ne dot all words s c h w a r z ok and we will also
describe a version for this dependency subversion 3.0.2 we will save the form dot XML file and use
this little button here to load the Maven changes let's click that and wait until the dependencies
are being loaded so as you can see it has turned white from red which means the dependencies have
been loaded successfully next up we will create a very simple env file inside src main resources
and we will just right click on the resources folder new and file we will call it dot env
now this env file will contain three values the first one is ora URI the second one is ora
user and the third one is ora password now as you may have already guessed the ora URI
is a URI to our neo4j server on the cloud the ora user is the name of the user or the username
and finally the password is for the password for the database now the ora user is going to be always
neo4j and i will just quickly copy that URI and password from my neo4j credentials file
okay so i have copied my URI and password from my credentials file and these are going to be
different in your case since your instance is different from mine now once you have created
this dot env file next up you will need to open the application dot properties file now inside
we are going to reference the three env values that we have so i will just say spring dot neo4j
dot URI and then a dollar sign curly braces and ora URI
next up is spring dot neo4j dot authentication dot username
again another dollar sign curly braces and ora user finally we say spring dot neo4j dot
authentication dot password it's a dollar sign curly braces or a password now why did we do this
why we didn't just put all these values inside our application dot properties class now the thing is
these values that URI to your instance the user password and the user name are secret values
these are things that you should never put on your github repository since the application
dot properties file is a part of your application we will not put our secrets directly into this
file instead we are going to create an env file and these three variables will be loaded into
our local environment and then the application properties will be able to find them using this
dollar sign and curly braces index this is how you actually access any of the environment variable
inside your application now i would suggest that you also make a copy of this file
and call it dot env dot example then get rid of these values
save the example file and make sure that your dot env file is being ignored inside your git ignore
file so inside here i will say dot env and i'll say dot env so this will make sure that the dot
env file is not added to your github repository instead you will have an example file that you
can use a reference to create a new env file okay so since we have our model controller
repositories and services in place and we also have our env file created our application should
be ready to connect to our database and give us a list of the courses let's test it out now to do
so you will have to click on the play button so far it looks like that the application is running
fine so what we are going to do is we are going to switch to an http client called insomnia and
we will test out our application by sending a request to it now inside insomnia the first
thing that you should do is create a new folder because we want to keep our requests organized
now i will call it spring boot neo4j
and i will move or just just let's get rid of this request now inside this folder
i will create a new http request this is going to be a git request of course
and this is going to http localhost 8080 slash api slash v1 slash courses i hope that you remember
and let's also rename this to
git all courses or something like that git all courses it really doesn't matter the difference
now let's send a request
yeah it looks like we have our list of courses as you can see we had four courses in our database
and all of those are being taught by gavin law and the list contains all of them and we also
have a 200 okay status code i hope you remember that we had added that little status http status
dot okay at the end so that's why you are getting the nice 200 okay responses so congratulations
on creating your first api endpoint in this application next up we are going to work on
the lessons and we will implement the relationship between the lessons and the courses and we will
also make sure that we can see the details of these individual courses along with the list of
the lessons so i am back at intelligia idea once again and now we are going to start working on
another endpoint for our application so let's go back to controllers now the next endpoint that i
want to work on is an endpoint that's going to return the details of a single course so if i go
back to insomnia let's make a copy of this request get single course and we will just pick an
identifier from all courses request we will put it inside the single request and we want to make
something like this now i actually like to start working from the lowest level of our application
which in our case are the repositories so i will go back to course repository and inside we are
finally going to create a custom method now this custom method will return an optional course
and we will call this method find course by identifier and then we'll take a string identifier
now the nice thing about these neo4j repositories is the fact that they are really smart
so just by the name of this method find course by identifier spring boot will know that we are
trying to find a course by using identifier property and we will also need to pass the
identifier by string now if i remove this part and i write it again i will say find
and as you can see integer idea actually recommends me that find course by so it can
sense that maybe we are trying to find a course by some parameter so i'm going to pick find course
by and then now it started to suggest me the possible property names and from this list i
am going to pick identifier and inside of course we are going to pass the identifier
let's say string identifier okay now we have the repository method we will go back to our service
which is the one step higher level of a repository and we will say public course
and we will call it get course by identifier and we will take the identifier as a string
now inside the method we will say return course repository dot find course by identifier
identify i hope that you remember that the method actually returns an optional type
and we are trying to return a course object from this method so what we are going to do
in the second line we will say or else throw so if you do not find this course or if you do not
find a course by this identifier throw side there we create a new lambda and we'll say new
new response status exception and we'll say HTTP status quote dot value of 404
so what we are saying is first use the find course by identifier method inside the course
repository and try to find a course by this identifier the identifier that i have passed
and in case you do not find a course using this identifier please throw a 404 not found
response exception status that's what we are doing let's close this service
and inside our controller we will create a new get mapping public
spawns entity of type course and we can call it course details
it has to be a get mapping and it will give us an identifier so we are we will get the
identifier from here and inside course details i will say path variable
which means we are going to get a variable from the path and it will be string identifier
yeah that's it you can call it anything else if you want
now inside the method what we are going to do is we will say return or or let's just create a course
course equals or service dot get course by identifier we will pass our identifier right here
and then we'll return a new response entity and we are going to say the course is the body
and HTTP status dot okay yeah so that's it what we are doing here is we are getting an identifier
in our path we are passing that identifier to our service layer that service layer in turn
we'll call our repository and get us the course that we are looking for now essentially this
should work so let's try out let's rerun our application go back to insomnia and let's
execute the get method that we created a bit earlier let's hit send
so as you can see it actually returns the course that we are looking for
and if we try to look for a course that doesn't exist for example if I add some garbage here
as you can see we are getting a 404 status now we are also getting a trace with it we may
configure our exceptional responses later on but for now we will just leave it like that
so let's get rid of the garbage let's send once again and yes we are getting the course details
now the thing is the response in the course detailed request and the course list request
is pretty much the same I think it would be nice if we could get the list of the lessons
that belongs to this course inside this details response right let's do that let's finally start
working on our lessons so I'll come back to intelligent I will create a new model
new
java class and it's going to be called lesson
this is going to be a node just like before it will have a long id
it is going to be the id and also a generated value
okay so I will have to import the I think there's something wrong with the id
yeah id sorry it didn't get imported first yeah next we would say private string title
and private string identifier so these are the three properties that we need
next up we will generate our empty constructor and our getter sunsetters
yes now before we try to implement our relationship between the lesson and courses
let's go back to our database and have a look at how it was mapped now if we focus on a single
course here as you can see this course has four lessons and each of these lessons has a belongs
to relationship with the course now from the point of view of a single lesson it has an outgoing
relationship of type belongs to with its parent course and from the point of view of the course
it has an incoming relationship of type belongs to with the lesson now with that information we
can actually implement these relationships in our models now back in our code we will open the
source code for the course model and we will describe a new property private list list of
lesson called lessons plus new error list now this list here is going to be a relationship this is
another annotation that comes with the dependency that we have used
and the type of the relationship is belongs to like we just saw in our database and the direction
from the point of view of the course it's an incoming direction
or an incoming relationship so the type of the relationship is belongs to and the direction
is relationship dot direction dot incoming now we will need a getter
we do not need a setter since we are not going to set this relationship manual we just need a getter
now since we have implemented the relationship we have implemented the
getter it should work let's rerun the application come back to insomnia make the request once again
and as you can see now the course comes back with the list of the lessons as you can see
this blazer shopping cart course has four lessons now this is all nice and cool but
there is a simple problem so if i go back to the get all courses and make a request
as you can see all the courses are coming back with the lessons now depending on what you want
from your application this may be something that you expect or you do not expect for example
in some places in my application i may not want the list of the lessons at all
because whenever a course is coming back with the list of lessons it's actually querying for
all these lessons so if i do not use the lessons this did that entire query time that that that
time my server is working is going to waste unfortunately there is no way that i know of
to leave out a relationship from a query so if you describe a relationship like that
you cannot actually lazy load it every time you will query for the courses you will also
get the relationship back now this is something that's not that hard to solve actually we can
write custom cipher queries to query for the lessons when they are needed and leave them out
when we don't to do that first let's get rid of the relationships from the model
also remove these because we are not going to use them
now at this moment in our code base the courses and lessons are totally unrelated to each other
but we have to implement some sort of relationships between them
now my idea is that we can have them unrelated in our code base but what we can do is we can
actually create another repository it will be another interface
let's call it lesson repository it extends the Neo4j repository the object will be lesson
and the id will be long and inside this repository we will implement another function that is list
lesson this is going to be the return type find lessons
by course identifier and we get the identifier as a string
okay now we have a method that is going to find a bunch of lessons using a course identifier now
the course identifier part is not a property of lesson so we cannot have an automatically built
method like this instead what we will do is we will write a very simple cipher query
so we'll say query then inside let's begin we'll say match and inside a set of parentheses
I will say colon course so we are looking for all the nodes of type course
inside I will say identifier
identifier so we are looking for a course node that has the same identifier as we have passed
to this method now once we have found this course we will need to get an incoming relationship
R of type belongs to and the related node should be lessons lesson and finally we have to return
the lessons let me explain what we are doing first we are trying to find a course node that
has the same identifier as the one we have passed to this method then we are looking for all the
lessons that are related to this course using an incoming belongs to relationship now once we have
found all the lessons we are putting them inside another variable called lessons and finally we
are returning the lessons in fact we can we can get rid of this R variable here since that's not
being used anywhere so the only piece of variable that we need is this one here once again we are
finding a course by the identifier that we have then we are looking for all the lessons that has
an incoming relationship with this course of type belongs to then we are putting those lessons
inside the lessons variable and returning them to the user so this is the query that we have
here now if everything goes fine it should return a list of the lessons okay the repository
is all set let's create a service lesson service this is going to be a service class
and inside the class we want a private final lesson repository lesson repository
we will have our constructor and we will have public first a list of lesson
and the name of the method should be get all lessons by course identifier
we will get a string identifier
and then inside the method we will say lesson repository dot find lessons by course identifier
and we will say identifier that's it and we can just return this directly
and yeah that's it that that's all we need in the lesson service
then inside the controllers as you can see right now we are returning a course
now this is all right but what would be better is if we return a dto or a data transfer object
so i'll just rename my config package to objects because we are not going to use the config right
now refactor and we will create a new class called course dto so this is a plain java class
inside i'll say private string identifier because i want the identifier for the course
i want private string and title i want the title for the course private string teacher
and private list list of lesson called lessons equals new error list excellent
oh it looks like we have to import the lesson class yes
finally we will have our constructor an empty constructor for that because we are going to
insert all these values later on or you know what we can get all this like this
constructor identified yes let's let's take these three and leave out the lessons because we are
going to fill it up later next we want to create some getters we need getters for everything
and we need a setter for the lesson
yes so that's that's all we need for the moment now let's go back to the course controller
inside this method instead of returning a course i will set course tto
and i have the course here then i will create course tto response course another object equals
to new course tto first i will need course dot get identifier next i need the title so course
dot get title comma finally course dot get teacher yeah those are the three
and then i will say response course dot set lessons and now we need to bring in our private
final lesson service lesson service here we need to add lesson service lesson service
and inside our constructor I will set this dot lesson service equals lesson service
yes we we have that initialized this looks fine to me now inside response course dot set lessons
I will say lesson service dot get all lessons by course identifier and course dot get identifier
so I will get all the lessons inside this course finally in the return statement instead of course
I will just set response course now technically if we have written everything correctly
this should give us the list of lessons along with the other course details
so I'll just restart my application
it has been restarted let's go back to insomnia send a request for a single course
and as it looks like we are still getting the list of the lessons but if I go back to get all
courses as you can see now there are no lessons at all so inside single course I can get the
lessons because I want them to be there and inside get all courses I do not need them so I don't have
them at all I hope you have understood how you can write a simple custom cipher query inside
java and this is going to be really helpful now creating this course dto class and later on we
are going to also create query results class these all things may seem like a lot of work to you but
to be honest once you have everything set up you have the code ready to go you will see how easy
it is to make changes because you are making sure that you are going you are abiding by the
separation of concerns and things like that so okay we have done that now one thing that I'd like
to say that the way the front end of our application has been created we actually
need the list of lessons in the list of courses as well so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
make some changes to it this list or the course index method and make sure that we are getting
the list of lessons there as well so I will change it to a course dto and yes the return
code return statement won't work anymore so I will copy this I'll say list course
once courses sorry courses and I'm getting a list of all the courses in our database
then what I'm going to do is I'm going to create another list of the course dto type
and this will be the response courses equals I will say courses dot string so I'm going to use
the stream API of java then I will call map inside map I will say course
it's going to be lambda actually
and here I will create a new course dto
course dto response course equals two I can actually copy this entire line
yes that I can also copy this line
after this yes response course dot lessons dot service so now I have a new course dto
and I need to return this so I'll say return response course and finally dot
collect characters dot to list so what I'm doing here I am getting the list of courses
from my database without the lessons then I am mapping through that list accessing
each course inside that list of courses I am creating a new dto object I am getting all
the lessons for that course and setting that inside my dto object and finally I'm returning
that response course from inside this lambda function and once I have returned that I am
creating a new list and adding that new response course to that list this is how it goes
so finally inside response entity I will just replace this part with response courses
HTTP status okay let's save our code and let's restart and see if it works fine or not
let's go back to insomnia
make a request for all the courses
and as you can see all the lessons are back in the course class so this far we have finally
implemented the courses we have implemented the lessons we have written some custom cipher query
so I think you have done a lot of work already to be honest now next up we are going to implement
the user model we will introduce an authentication system to this application so that users can
log in and once that done we can finally work on the course enrollments so let's continue working
on it now that we have finished implementing the courses and lessons it's time to finally
work on the user now before we start writing our code for the user related functionalities
we will need to add a new dependency so open up your pom.xml file
then write after a spring.env add a new dependency now the name of this dependency will be
spring boot starter security and its group id will be simply org.spring framework.boot
like all the other starter packages in fact let's do one thing let's cut this chunk of code from here
and put it right after the starter data new port shared that way we will have all our starter
packs inner in a line and then we will have the other dependencies so once you have added
this dependency to your project just hit this load maven changes button
okay it looks like the dependency has been resolved now let's try to restart our application
and you should see something like this using generated security password the generated
password is for development use only and things like that so this means that
spring security is actually working now to test it out we can go back to insomnia
we can send one of our old requests
and you will see that it says 401 unauthorized which means that the spring security system
is stopping us from accessing this endpoint now this is totally normal by default spring security
stops all the requests to the server but you can use an username and password to get access
to the data you want now for that let's go back to our IDE look for your application.properties
file inside src main and resources now after the three lines that we added before
we will have to add two more lines these are spring.security.user.name
and I will set it to Farhan spring.security.user.password equals to password
now let's go back to insomnia here you can see there is the auth menu right beside body so I
will go inside auth I will click on this arrow and pick basic auth now inside here I will add
the username Farhan and password is password then I will send the request
okay it looks like we forgot to restart our application so let's do that
now insomnia send the request
and it worked out just fine but I know what you are thinking this is not the right way to authenticate
any request we want to use the users in our database right don't worry we are going to do
that but before I just wanted to show you how you can make your request go through the spring
security gate now let's disable the authentication okay let's go back to our IDE and start working on
a proper authentication system first let's remove these two values
close the properties stop our application and minimize the terminal now we will start by
creating a new model named user now unlike the models that we have worked on before the user
is going to implement an interface so we will write implements user details now this interface
is actually part of the security package that we just added and it describes a few
methods and properties that makes this model usable for our authentication system so we can hover
over it and it says implement methods we will click that and it it shows us a bunch of methods
we will say okay and now we have a lot of overrides let's just close this sidebar for
more space okay so these are the methods that we want to implement so let's start with
get password and get username because those are the easiest one we will say private string
username private string password then inside get password we will return password and inside
username we will return username excellent now those two have been taken care of next we will add
the roles so it's a private string roles i hope that you remember from our database view from
before that every single users has a bunch of roles so this is what we are going to do here
now once you have added the roles we want to implement the get authorities method which is
this one now this is sort of an special kind of method that actually returns all the authorities
or roles for this user now you may have seen that i had added a role user value to our
users in our database but you can have something like role admin role teacher and so on you can
also have role admin comma role teacher role moderator and so on but for now we are dealing
with a single role now this method here it returns a collection and that extends the granted authority
interface so what we need to do is we will say return we need the arrays class from java.util
and then we will say dot stream inside the stream method we need our roles so the roles
that we have defined here we'll say roles.split and we want to split it by a comma because remember
we can have roles like this role admin role teacher so we want to split it using this comma
after splitting let's come to the next line and we will say map we will say simple
granted authority which is a class and we will add new at the end and dot to list
see and we are returning this list so what we are doing here we are getting the value
of the roles string from this user we are splitting the string using the commas so just
in case you decide to add multiple roles to this user and then we are mapping through that new
you know splitted string and creating new simple granted authorities using the string value that
we get from our map call finally once we have multiple or a single simple granted authority
instance we are adding them to a list and returning that list from this method so since
list are part of collections this checks out now if you are confused about this method i
would suggest that you do some more study on how spring security works and how you can implement
multiple roles for users so that's a bit out of the scope of this course so this is what we have
to do now next up let's go inside is account non-expire we want to return true here
then is account non-locked yes we want to return true is credentials non-expired true
and also is the account enabled yes true so that's it we have successfully implemented the
user details interface but other than these three we also need an id and we need a private string
name for the user now like the other models this id is going to be an id and it is going
to be a generated value and we will need a getter and setter for our name
so let's come at the end of all these overrides or maybe
maybe here let's come to this place and we'll say alt insert we will generate a getter
for our id no i mean our name we will also need a setter for our name
there you go now in the case of this user model we will actually use our id field
so we will also add a getter for that and since we are going to create new users we will also
need setters for our username and password and roles so let's scroll down and come to get password
and i will come after it and insert a setter for our password there we have it next after the get
username i will insert a setter for our username and finally we do not have a get roles method
but we have this one so i will just come after this and i will put a setter for our roles
there you go it looks like the model is ready to be used and you know what let's just generate
a getter for our roles as well because even though we have this get authorities method
we may also need a plain old getter for our roles string so let's just add the getter and it looks
like everything has been set up finally i i would just like to check the generate menu once again
to see if we have anything left yeah we have left id setter but we are not going to need that
so once you are done with that let's just close this and we will now create a new package
called config
next up let's create a new repository so i will right click on the repositories package
creating a java class it has to be an interface and name it user repository
like the other repositories i want to extend new 4j repository and that's all we need for now
we will come back to this because we will add two more custom queries to this repository but
those are not needed at the moment finally we will go inside service and we are going to create an
special service for our authentication system so we will create a new class called
neo user details service you may call it something else like neo4j user details service the thing is
this is going to be an user detail service that we will in turn use with spring security
so we have this class and it's going to implement another interface called user details service
and just like the model we will implement the methods there is only one method load user by
username and that's pretty much it so as you can say from the name of this method these can return
a user using its username so for that we will go back to our user repository
we will create a method that returns an optional user and we will call it find
user sorry i have made a mistake we will have to tell it the name of the model
as well as the type of id we are using all right now we can say find user by username
we will receive the username as and string this is very simple method and that's all we need
now inside our new user details service i will explain why we need this class in a bit but
for now just write the class along with me so i will create a private final user repository
then i will have a constructor there you go and then as you can see this method here returns
the type user details this is one of the interfaces that comes with the spring security framework
so instead of returning null what we are going to do is return
sorry user repository dot or let's come to the next line find user by username
we will pass the username that we have here and then on the third line we will say or else throw
and inside the method we will create a new lambda new username not found exception
and we will pass a message username not found then can just add the username to the message
yeah so that's what we have so as you can see the user details service interface implements
a method called load user by username so what we are doing here we are using our repository
instance and we are calling the find user by username method now it returns an optional
user so if we have the user then we will return it and if we do not have the user then we will
throw a new username not found exception and we have to throw this exception because
by the definition of this interface this method has to throw a username not found exception
in cases where the username is not found so that's all we need here now finally we are
going to write the big chunk of authentication code that we will need to use our database
instead of some preset user so go inside project i will collapse everything then go inside
source main java and as you can see i have a package called config so i will right click
and create a new class called security config by the way the service class that we created
has to be annotated with the service annotation yeah so all the service classes have been
annotated okay so inside the security config class we have to annotate it with configuration
then enable web security okay then inside the class we will create a private final
new user details service we will have a constructor and then we are going to create
a bin and that bin is of type security filter chain new security filter chain
it will receive HTTP security this one we will call it HTTP security and this throws
an exception okay let's annotate with the bin annotation so that
neo4j will handle the task of instantiating this class and everything inside this method
we will create a new security filter chain once we have finished working on it you will
understand what it actually does so we'll say return HTTP security this one then dot session
management inside we will say session create a new lambda session dot session creation policy
then session creation policy dot stateless because since we are creating an API the
authentication has to be stateless then we are going to disable CSRF protection because
we don't need that for that we will use abstract HTTP configurator yes this one
and disable okay then on the next line we will say course because we are going to
customize our course customizer dot with defaults so course will be configured with the default
settings finally we'll say authorize HTTP requests inside we'll say auth and auth dot
it will say request matchers yes and inside the request matchers we will say
api slash v1 slash auth slash me okay let's leave it to that for now we will add more routes to it
later i'll say dot authenticated and dot any request dot permit off finally we will finish
this by saying user details service neo user details service dot HTTP basic customizer dot with
defaults and dot built ah that's a lot of code right so let us take a look and try to understand
what's happening here so by default the spring security framework uses a security filter chain
that logs any request to your server you will have to authenticate for every single request
to the server and we do not want that also in the default security filter chain it uses your
application dot properties file or a randomly generated user as an authenticable user we also
do not want that we want to use the users in our database so for that we will need to create a new
security filter chain that will essentially define how we want to secure our application
so inside this bin i hope you understand what beans are beans are just java classes that are
managed by the spring boot framework so we are creating a new bin that is of type security
filter chain and it throws an exception okay so inside this bin we are saying return HTTP security
which is of type HTTP security this is one of the classes that comes with the spring security
framework and the first thing that we are doing is we are making the session stateless i know
this is a long line but all this does is it makes the sessions stateless so we do not hold any
session data whatsoever then we are disabling the CSRF securities because since it is an API and
we essentially do not have any web interfaces within this particular application or service
we can successfully disable the CSRF protection then we are configuring cores so in an application
where there is no spring boot security framework you have to customize your core settings somewhere
else but since we are using spring boot security this framework is going to intercept the request
first and then it will pass it to the application or other configures so we have to configure the
cores right in the security filter chain configuration thing so right now we are
customizing the core settings with the default ones but we are going to change it very soon
then we are saying authorize HTTP request so this is the method where we will define
which routes has to be protected by our application and which routes do not need to be protected
so inside we have an auth object and we are using the request matchers method to say that
hey spring boot security you have to protect any request to this particular endpoint we haven't
created this endpoint here and you only need to stop any request coming to this endpoint and
all the other requesters any requests just permit them to connect so when we get a request
in this particular endpoint it needs to be authenticated any other request should be
permitted now next up we will actually configure our parse configurations so we will say
parse configure or cause configuration source yes this one we want this one
and then we will say cause configuration source we will start the method and we will
annotate with a bin now inside this bin we will say parse configuration
parse configurations equals to new parse configuration so we are creating a new
course configuration then we are going to change things in this configuration so we will say
course configuration dot set allowed origins so which origins are we allowing so i will just say
array let's check what it takes so it looks like
it takes a list of the strings so i will say array
okay dot as list arrays dot as list and i will create a string HTTP local host 3000
and also just in case HTTP
127.0.0.1 which is localhost as well 3000 so i have been made aware by Gavin Long that the
react application that he will be working on will run on localhost 3000 or 127.0.0.1 port 3000 so
what i have done i have allowed these two origins to connect to my to my application
now this is one way of doing things to be honest these two values these should be resided inside
our.env file but i am not going to do that since i have shown you how to use a.env file
i will just add a todo here which says make sure that the origin list comes from an environment
file so i would suggest that the viewers or you essentially take this as a challenge and implement
this part using an.env file put your code on github and share the link in the comment section
i will take my time to go through every single code shared in the comment section and i will
make sure that everything is right so this is one of the challenges i will add that as a todo and
you can actually click on this button here todo and you can see what challenges i have set
so that's one challenge then the second one is cause configuration dot set
allowed methods and what methods are we allowing arrays dot as list this also takes a list so
this is how you are going to do get and we will do post we will do patch
patch then put delete
options
and hit these are all allowed methods then we'll say cause configuration dot
set allowed credentials yes this one and we'll set true nice then we will say cause configuration
dot set allowed headers and arrays dot as list authorization request type content
and so these are the three headers that we want to allow
finally we'll say configuration dot set exposed headers and it will be called arrays dot as list
next inside here we will say x get header and lastly we will have cause configuration dot set
max h we will let's say let's do it 3600 l so l for long next let's let's just create an url
based course configuration source so we'll say url based course configuration source and url
based course configuration source calls to new url based course configuration source here try
saying that 10 times faster right url based course configuration source yeah i can do that
and we will say URL based course configuration source yes dot register
course configuration and we want to apply this configuration to all the
routes in our application so that's what this pattern means so this is the root
and anything that comes up at that then we'll say comma and course configuration
yeah nice finally we have to return our URL based course configuration source
okay so now we have our course configured one last thing that we have to
configure is actually a password encoder so I believe you remember when I showed
you our database architecture that we are saving the password for the users as
big script encrypted hashes we are not saving plain text passwords because you
should never do that so we will need to let the Spring Boot security to know what
encoder we are using but to do that I will say password encoder password
encoder this is another bean I will annotate this one with bean and then
inside the method I will say return new be ripped password encoder and end it
there so yes we have done most of things oh by the way I think I have missed this
three lines so what we are saying here is we need to let the security filter
chain know which user details service are we going to use and in our case we
have a custom user details service which is the new user details service and what
we have inside this class we have implemented a single method that helps
us to use or look for the user so every time some user tries to log into our
application the spring security filter chain will use these details service
look for the user and then check the password against the hash that we have
saved in our database using this password encoder and if it matches it
will let the request pass through and if it doesn't it will throw a username not
found exception so finally we are going to use an HTTP basic authentication I
know this is pretty insecure but for the scope of this project or this application
this is totally fine I could have implemented a more sophisticated JWT
based authentication but that will take a lot more time and a lot more code so I
want to focus more on the on the Neo4j and spring boot connectivity rather
than the authentication and security part of the application so this is what
we are going for so now that we have configured our security thing let's let's
just go ahead and create this endpoint so we will go to project and we will
create a new controller and it will be called user controller let's annotate
this one as a REST controller and request mapping to API slash p1 slash auth
inside we will have a single method for now which will be public logged in user
and we will create an endpoint which will be a get mapping and it will be
called me finally inside this logged in user we have to define our return type
which will be string for now and we will get something called the principal I will
explain what principal is and we will say return principal dot get name so
okay let's make sure that this endpoint is right so let's go back to our config
API v1 auth me so everything checks out hmm okay then let's start our
application and try to log in using one of the users in our database
right now we are inside our Neo4j dashboard and we can see all the users
in our database so I am going to just select John price and the user name is
just price now the password for all these users such as Mirza Mikhail or
Mac Milan the password is actually password I have already encoded the
password using big script and saved the hash so I will just copy the username of
John price price and let's go back to our insomnia then right now if I make a
request without any authentication it should work because the single course
and get all courses endpoints have not been protected I hope that you remember
that the only endpoint that is protected right now is the me endpoint so I create
a new HTTP request I will call this me HTTP localhost 8080
API slash v1 slash auth slash me and if I send a request as you can see I am
getting 401 unauthorized but if I go inside auth select basic auth and as the
username I will say price price and for password I will say password let's see
if it works or not so as you can see this time we are getting 200 so what's
happening here let's go back to our code and let me explain it to you now right
now we have a single endpoint called slash API v1 auth me and according to
our security configuration this is one of the protected route and we have to be
authenticated to hit this route inside this method we are getting a principal
object and this principal object usually contains information about what user is
authenticated right now so once you send in your username and password our
security config will intercept that and pass that to the user details service
the user details service in turn will look for an user using the username that
we have got from the user and if it finds the username it will give it back
otherwise it will throw a username not found exception once the filter chain
has found an user it will get the password from that user and check its
hash against the password submitted by the user using this password encoder and
you may ask how does the filter chain gets the password well if I go back to
models user and you will see we have a getter for the password get password and
this is a part of the user details interface so that's how it gets the
password hash and if the user is giving the right username and password he will
pass otherwise he will not pass so that's how this entire authentication
system works and if you have done anything right you should be able to
authenticate new users to your application now that we have our user we
can finally begin working on the enrollment part so if user can actually
look at our courses and enroll in the ones that they like so that's what we
are going to do now now that our users can log into our system we want to
create a way for them to register in our system so we have a way to log in now we
need a way to register so before we start writing the code for registering
the user I would like to create a few packages and classes now the first one
is a package called requests and inside here I will create a new Java class
called create user request now I will explain what it will do but just follow
along for now then inside this class we will say private string name private
string user name private string password private string roads so everything that
the user model has except the ID field next up we will create a constructor and
this time we will pick all of them and after that I will just create some
getters and setters okay the request class is ready let's close that next what
we need is a user DTO object so user DTO and this one is going to be really
simple private string name private string user name private string roads we
do not want to return the password in our responses so we will just leave that
out next we want to create the constructor and the getters and setters there
you go we have a user DTO now next we need to create a service called user
service user service and this one has to be annotated as a new service for sure
then we will need a private user repository user repository let's let's
make it final and then we will have private final password encoder password
encoder because we want to encode our users password then I will have my
constructor and a function public and this is going to return a user create
user and this will take a create user request not any request but create user
request and create a new user so I will say user user equals to new user then I
will say user dot set name request dot get name and I hope you remember that we
just implemented this get name method inside the create user class so that's
why we can use that then user dot set username request dot get username nice
user dot set roles request dot get roles user dot set password and this is
where the encoder will come in and I will say password encoder dot encode
inside there I will say request dot get password so this will take what the
password is that we got from the user and then encode it and set it as the
user's password finally we would say user repository dot save user the safe
method comes with all the repositories and we will return the user that's it we
have our service method ready to go let's go to the controller now and here
I will say public and then response entity of type user DTO
sign up and this will take request body and map that to create user request we'll
call it request let's go inside the method and I will say oh I will also
need a reference to our private final user service user service and I need my
constructor then I can say user service dot create user and I can just pass the
request to it and it returns a user then I will create a user DTO response user
equals to new user DTO now first I need the name so user dot get name then user
dot get user name and user dot get roles that's all I need then I can just
return a new response entity and the body will be the response user and the
status will be created because we have just created a new user so yeah that's
all we need to sign up a new user and this is really easy to do I will have to
create a post mapping or register yeah that's all we need now we can go back to
insomnia and check if this works so I'll just start my application then I will
switch to insomnia and I will create a new request vault register
okay this will have a body first we need a name so I will do for home
a scene children comma I need an username
for home then I need a password
and I will need a role string so it will be the whole user make sure you are
writing the role like this and then I send the request to HTTP local host API
slash v1 slash auth slash register that's it I believe
okay let's change it to post and we do not need any authentication for this and
let's hit send so looks like a new user has been registered it says 201 and the
username is Farhan now there are two ways to verify if the registration has
gone through correctly or not first I can go to my me request I can go to
basic and instead of price I can say Farhan and the password is password I
will say send and it looks like it gives me back Farhan which means the user has
been registered to database but still if we quickly switch to our database
dashboard then click on user once again
it got me back all the users and as you can see Farhan has in show 3 is right
here but right now Farhan or me I am NOT enrolled in any of the courses so next
we are going to work with the enrollment process and we are make we are going to
make sure that all the users can actually enroll in a class but before
that I would like to give another challenge for you so if I go back to the
user service as you can see right now I am NOT checking if this username has
been already registered or not so I will leave it to you so that you can figure
out how to check if a thing exists on the database using spring boot data or
spring data repositories and make a decision on that so I will add another
to do and I will say make sure that these username does assist and let's
just come back from here and I put that over the username so this is another to
do that I am leaving out for you I will look forward to any submission in in the
comment section and I will actually let you know if anything is wrong with the
code so let's close that and start working on our enrollment process now
before I write anything in my services or in my controllers I would like to
make sure that we have all the necessary queries in our repositories for example
in order to enroll user in a new course we will have to create a new
relationship between the user and the course so like I showed you before you
can actually do that through the models but in this case I am going to create a
custom query that will have a custom query result and you can use that to
create a new enrollment relationship so for that I will go to my repositories
and then user repositories and I will write two methods here the first one is
going to be a boolean and it will be called find enrollment status so you can
use this method to check whether a user is already enrolled in a course or not
and I will take a string username and I will also take a string identifier which
is the course identifier in our case so we are going to write a custom query
just like we did before and it will go something like match user user or this
has to be a string of course comma there'll be a course course and then
fire user dot username equals dollar sign username so this variable right
here and user sorry course dot identifier equals dollar sign identifier
right here this variable so what we are doing is we are querying for a user that
has the same user name as we have passed to this method and then we are looking
for a course that has the same identifier as we have passed in this
method and we are saving the user in a variable called user and the course in a
variable called course next we want to give a space and then enter so that we
can begin on the next line and then we'll say return exists
we will say user
and rolled in
yeah that's pretty much it so what we are doing is we are looking for a user
and course against the username and identifier that we have and then we are
checking if there is any outgoing relationship from the user with the
course of type enrolled in so I believe you remember that back when we are
designing our database we had a relationship called enrolled in and it
was an outgoing relationship from the point of view of the user and an
incoming relationship from the point of view of the course so there we go we can
use this use this method to check whether a user is already enrolled in a
course next up we want to create a query that we can use to create a new
enrollment now before we do that we need another class so we will create a new
package query results and inside that we will create a new class called course
enrollment query request or query result sorry query result now this is a very
simple class we will say private user user private course course and we need
to import these classes obviously yes
okay we have both the classes then we will have an empty constructor like
that and we will have some getters and setters so alt insert and getter and
setter both of these so there you go we have a course enrollment query result
object now if I come back and I create a new method and this is going to return a
course enrollment query result I would call it create enrollment relationship
basically you want to be explicit with your names and I will need a username
also I will need an identifier now the first bit of this query is identical to
this one so what I am going to do is I will copy this entire match part come
inside this method I will say query put it in space and then enter now on the
next line I would like to say create user in fact you can just copy this this part
here so we are going to we are going to create a new outgoing relationship from
the user to the course of type enrolled in then finally we'd like to return the
user and the course now as you can see this query returns a really complex data
it returns an user object and it also returns a course object so like other
custom queries like this one we cannot just say that these returns a boolean
type instead we had to create our own custom class that has an user object and
a course object and use that as the result of this query so this is how you
can map complex queries to custom meant classes okay so our user repository is
now ready to go I believe we can enroll our users to classes now but we cannot
just put the code for course enrollment inside the user service or user
controller or the course controller at all instead what we are going to do is
we will create a new service called course enrollment service and it will be
a class a service class then inside there we will have a few methods now the
first method that we have but before that we will need a private final course
repository course repository and private final user repository user repository now
this service can access both repositories because we are going to
work with both courses and enrollment but if we had to put this code inside
the core service then we would need to unnecessarily refer to the user
repository inside the course core service that doesn't feel good at all
that's why we have a separate service for you know creating the enrollments
so inside we will have a constructor
and we will have a few methods now the first method would be public boolean get
enrollment status and for that we will need a username and a course identifier
then inside the method we will just say return course repository dot check sorry
user repository dot find enrollment status and we will pass it the user name
and the course identifier so this way we can use this method to check if a
given username is enrolled in a course or not now the next thing we need is
public and this is going to return a course enrollment query result and it
will be called enroll in and it will also need a username and a course
identifier okay we will return user repository dot create enrollment
relationship username and identify okay so yeah we are done with these two
methods we will need one last method that is we need public list of courses
and we will call it get all enrolled course by user name a string username
and a string identifier okay so what this method is going to do is if we
give it a username it will give us back the list of courses that user is enrolled
in and I just realized we really do not need the identifier now we do not have
a repository method for this so let's go to our course repository and create a new
method this will return a list of courses and we will call it find all
enrolled courses by username and we receive a string username and then we
can say query match we are trying to match a user
where the username is username so this is another way of doing a query or
query clause so we will have a user with the same username that has been passed
to this method then once we have that node we want to get enrolled in
courses course so we want to get all the courses that has an outgoing relationship
with this user of type enrolled in and I'm saving all those courses in the
forces variable and I will just return forces and we will also import the list
method java.util of course and yet that's it so let's go back here and we
will say return course repository dot find all enrolled course by username and
we'll just pass the username so that's it we have our course enrollment
service ready to go we can use it to enroll our users in a new course we can
get the enrollment status of a user and we can also get all the enrolled courses
by username and I just realized it should be courses and not just course so
there you go okay now I think we are ready to create a new controller the
controller will be named course enrollment controller like the other ones
it's going to be a rest controller for sure okay let's just go back to our
service class for a bit course enrollment service and yeah we have
annotated it yeah and we will do a request mapping API slash v1 slash
enrollment now this enrollments endpoint these need to be protected because if
you go back to our service for example course enrollment service you can see
all these methods needs to know that username of the currently authenticated
user so for that we need to protect this route so we will leave the controller
open and get back to config and security config let's let's close this and come
to the request matchers part I will put a comma and I will say API slash v1 slash
enrollments slash double star which means anything that comes after API
slash v1 slash enrollment slash anything should be authenticated or protected
let's close that and inside our controller class we will need a few
services so I will say private final course enrollment service course
enrollment service and we will also need private final lesson service lesson
service because we will need to know what lessons are part of a certain course
now I will have my constructor and we can start working on the endpoints now
the first one I want to do is I want to let the user enroll in a course so for
that I will say public response entity of type course enrollment DTO and we
need to create this class create class course enrollment DTO and we want to put
it inside the objects package and here we have our DTO
we need string
private string user name so the user name of the user that has just enrolled
in the course private is string name of the user private course and the course
that the user just enrolled in then we will have a constructor and we will have
the getters and setters yeah that's pretty much it so you want to return a
course enrollment DTO and we will call our method enroll in now what we are
going to take we are going to take the request body request body and we will
create another request called course enrollment request let's hover over it
and create type parameter course enrollment request you know what let's
just copy the name go to project go to requests create a new class or course
enrollment request and inside this we need
private string identifier this is the course identifier of course and we will
generate a constructor and the getters and setters okay let's go back to our
code request body course enrollment request so we will have our course
enrollment request comma another thing that we need is the principal sorry I
forgot to name this so I will get principal principal because this is how
you get the username of the authenticated user now inside this
method we will say course enrollment query result let's call it enrollment
query result yes equals we will say course enrollment service dot enroll in
what is the user name the principal dot get name and what is the identifier
request dot get identifier terrible we have a new enrollment request query
right query result now we cannot just return this query result for a button or
verbatim rather we will need a new DTO called course enrollment DTO now I will
over operate some more action okay let's again just copy this photo project go
inside objects how it looks like we have a course enrollment DTO create I just
forgot about this so what I will do is course enrollment DTO we have that yeah
I just forgot that we created this so response enrollment equals new the first
thing that we need to pass is the username so we will say enrollment query
result dot get user dot get username because our query result has a get user
method that in turn returns a get username method and we can use that to
get the name of the user or the username of the user next up we have the name of
the user so enrollment query result dot get user once again dot get name and you
know what this line is getting too big so I will just put it in the next line
comma let's bring down here yeah much better enrollment query request dot get
course that's pretty much it or we need the username name and the course finally
we can say return new response entity the body will be the response enrollment
and the HTTP status should be okay but it really depends upon you since we have
created a new relationship you could have also returned created here but I'm
going to just return okay now this is going to be a post mapping let's try and
enroll our user in a course okay let's check our request once again we just
need an identifier so that's what we are going to do I will go back to my
insomnia client I will create a new request called
enroll this is going to be HTTP localhost 8080 slash API slash v1 slash
enrollments and inside this has to be a post request by the way and inside the
body we need an identifier so let's go inside get single course this one go
back to enroll and we'll put it here let's click on send
yeah I just remembered I didn't restart my code so let's go back to IDEA and do
that
and I will send
nice we are getting a 401 unauthorized response because we are not
authenticating any user so I will go to basic auth I add Farhan and password is
password let's send the request so it looks like that we should leave the
course enrollment request as an empty constructor instead of taking the
identifier as one of its parameters because if we do that the request may
or not work so I am keeping it empty and now when I try to create an enrollment
from insomnia it just works as you can see Farhan has been enrolled in Blazor
shopping cart application course so to verify we can quickly go to our RDD
dashboard and if we click on enrolled in we should see that Farhan has seen
cho3 is now enrolled in the Blazor shopping cart course now other than
verifying from the database itself we also want a way to get the list of all
the courses a user has been enrolled in so we have already created a service
method for that so let's just go back to our controller and implement that so
here inside our controller we will create a new gate mapping method so
public response entity this is going to be a list of the course DTO and we will
call it enrollments we will take the principal because we need the username
and inside this method we will say list course so courses equals course
enrollment service dot get all enrolled course by username and we will say
principal dot get name now we have a list of courses that the user has been
enrolled in on the next line we will say just like before a list of course DTO
and response courses equals courses dot stream dot map inside the map method we
will say course this is a lambda course sorry course DTO response course
equals new course DTO and we need an identifier title and teacher name so I
will say course dot get identifier course dot get title and course dot get
teacher and then I can just return response course and finally after this
curly brace and the last parentheses I will say collect collectors dot to list
so this is just like we did before with the courses list so I'm not going to
again explain this and I will say return new response entity response courses
comma HTTP status dot okay all right we this is a get mapping of course there
you go let's restart our application
go back to insomnia make a copy of the enroll request and call it in roll
meant turn it into a get request get rid of the identifier make sure that we are
authenticating and let's hit send okay so looks like we have a list of the
courses that this user has been enrolled in what we need is we need the list of
lessons too so let's go back to our controller I'm going to steal some code
from the course controller class I hope you remember inside this one we actually
made use of the lesson service so I'll copy this line I will go back to course
enrollment controller
and put it down here
course enrollment dot set lesson and then return the response course we will
rerun the application
we will go back to insomnia resend our request and this time we are actually
getting the list of all the lessons as well now that's pretty much it we have
done a lot with our applications except I want to implement one last thing in
in our code so I you may remember that we have implemented the code necessary
for a service and repository method that returns a boolean based on whether an
user is enrolled in a course or not so in our list of courses I would like to
add a new boolean variable here that says enrolled in and that will return
true if the user is enrolled in a course and false in case he or she is not
enrolled in a course so let's go back to our code what we can do is we will go
back to our course DTO and inside we want to add a new boolean so private boolean
let's use a primitive type and is in rolled that's it now we will need a
getter and setter for this one
yes we got that now let's go back to course enrollment controller and we will
say response course dot set enrolled and we are going to hard code it to true
since the user just enrolled in this course we know for sure that this is
going to be true so we will not make another database request and just write
it as true but inside our course controller
we will actually have to do a database call for that we will take the
principal and we will add a check here we will say if principal is not null
then response course dot set enrolled inside we will say we need another
service private final course enrollment service course enrollment service and
we'll say course enrollment service yes that's a lot of boilerplate to be honest
course enrollment service yeah so inside set enrolled we will say course
enrollment service dot get enrollment status and principal dot get name and
course dot get identifier so we are checking whether the user has enrolled
in the course or not now why we are checking for principal is null or not I
hope you remember that in our course index anyone can see the list of our
courses because it's an open directory so in case we do not get any principal
or authenticated user we will just set it to false a set enrolled and if we get
a principal we will set it to whatever the database returns so I will rerun
the application and show you how it works
let's quickly switch to insomnia and get all courses
but as you can see it says enrolled false in all of these because I am NOT
logged in but if I log into my account for Han password and hit send
you will see that it says true on the blazer shopping cart application and
falls in all of the other ones now why we are here I thought I will make one
little adjustment to our code that is in enroll we are sending something called
an identifier now this is not clear I think what would be better if we could
call it course identity fire this is a lot better I think so I will go back to
my code go inside the course enrollment request right click on the identifier
and go inside refactor rename so instead of identifier I would like to call it
course identifier I'll hit enter yeah these are all the references and get
course identifier course and yes we are going to let's make sure that these are
right
yeah let's see it okay let's rerun our application and see everything works
fine or not okay it looks fine so that's pretty much it we have successfully
implemented the ability to enroll in a new course the user can get the list of
enrollments the user can register the user can sign in and see the lessons in
the course now on the next part of this course Gavin long will walk you through
the entire process of creating and react app based on this API he will show how
you can use the identifiers to get the corresponding YouTube videos and how you
can basically create a course management system front-end for yourself powered by
my API now one last challenge that I would like to leave for the user is
inside the services and course enrollment service before we enroll our
user in a course we need to make sure that the user has not been enrolled in
the course already so this is something that we have to make sure right now if
you try to enroll the same user twice in a course you will create two
relationships to the same course so it will get you will get double results so
what you should do is you should check whether the user has already been
enrolled in the course using the game enrollment status maybe I don't know I'm
giving a hint and then you should enroll the user in the course or return
something else now this is another challenge that I'm leaving up to you so
if you go inside to do you will get three to-dos and one is in the config
and two is in the services so make sure that you are completing your challenges
it will give you a lot more confidence to be honest and you will learn a lot
from your researchers make sure that you leave the link to your repository in the
comment section below I will come there I will check the core submissions and I
think it would be a nice conversation between us so I hope that throughout
this entire course or this part of the course you have learned something about
the Neo4j database which truly is an amazing technology you have learned how
to create an API powered by Neo4j on Spring Boot and a few other things here
and there on how to structure your application how to use an IDE and things
like that so if you ever need any help just give me a shout out in the comment
section I would love to help and best of luck for the rest of the course Gavin
Lon is an amazing instructor and I can say for sure that you will have a great
time so until the next time take care and be careful bye before we get
started with coding this react application I need to let you know that
I've had to make a few assumptions regarding the knowledge and experience
of the viewers of this part of the course so ideally the viewer of this
part of the course should have at least a basic knowledge of react JavaScript
HTML and CSS so let's start with the very basics we of course need a code
editor for writing our react code I will be using Visual Studio code for
Windows for this purpose you can download Visual Studio code for Windows
from this URL in order to run our code locally we need to install node.js
you can install node.js from this URL node.js is an open source cross-platform
JavaScript runtime environment
we need a local working directory to house our applications code
so please create a working folder in a location of your choosing on your
computer and let's give our working folder a sensible name my working folder
for this project is curriculum mngt management client so curriculum mngt client
then let's open the working directory for our project within Visual Studio
code note we can check what version of node we have installed while we're in
Visual Studio code we can do this by first launching the terminal window
launch the terminal window by pressing control and the tilde character then at
the command prompt type node-v and press enter great and we can see what version
of node we have installed on our computers an easy way to set up a react
project is to use the create-react-app command we can use this command to
generate the infrastructure for our react application when I say
infrastructure I mean the node modules that are necessary for harnessing
foundational react functionality is generated through the use of the
create react app command there are other ways perhaps better ways of creating the
foundations for a react project like for example using a technology named VIT for
this purpose if you are interested please read more about VIT at this
location using the create react app command provides a simple way to create
a react project so I'm going to use the create react app command for this
purpose at the command prompt type npx create react app followed by a sensible
name for your react application I'm going to name my react application
curriculum dash mngt mngt of course stands for management then let's press
the enter key this process may take a while so this will give you an
opportunity to contemplate life the universe okay you don't have to do that
but you may want to get yourself a cup of tea or something like that while you
wait
okay great and you can see that the foundation for our react project has been
generated the node modules directory has been created which contains all the
react dependencies and packages needed to build and run a react project as you
can see a new route directory for our project has been generated that is of
the name that we gave our application when we ran the create react app command
so for better clarity let's open another instance of visual studio code where the
newly created project directory is the root directory within visual studio code
to do this let's make sure the terminal window is launched remember you can do
this by pressing the control key and the tilde key then at the command prompt
make sure the current projects working directory is the current directory at
the command prompt then type CD space and then the root directory of the react
project then press the enter key now at the command prompt type code followed by
space and then the period character then press the enter key this will result in
a new instance of visual studio code being presented and now the react
project folder is the root directory
now let's close the previously launched instance of visual studio code the
create react app command has generated the infrastructure for our react project
but has also generated a few files that we don't need so let's delete the
following files that we don't need report web vitals.js set up tests.js and
app.test.js
we must also delete the ESLint config setting from the package.json file
here
let's save our changes then lastly let's open the index.js file and delete the
code regarding report web vitals great
so we are now ready to develop our react application so at the moment we have very
basic functionality that has been generated for us by default through the
use of the create react app command so let's ensure that we start off on a good
footing as it were this lets us know that all is working as it should be
before we start developing our application so to launch the react app
in our default browsers we can type npm space start at the command prompt and
press the enter key
great and we can see the react logo spinning which means we are good to go
so let's start creating the code for our application within the SRC directory
where the source code will reside let's create a subdirectory named components
as you have probably guessed we are going to create our react components
within the components directory let's also create a directory within the SRC
directory named images
please download this image from this location on github and ensure that this
image file resides within the images directory we are going to use this image
as our hero image on our home page so this image will be referenced from
within the home component the first react component we are going to create is
the home component this component denotes the page that will first be
displayed when our application is first launched so let's create a directory
within the components folder named home the first letter of this folder name
should be in lowercase within the home folder let's create a file named home.js
the first letter of this file should be an uppercase so we can use a shortcut to
generate boilerplate code for our home component to do this type rafce like
this within the code editor and press the enter key note that in order to
utilize the rafce shortcut you must first install the appropriate react
snippets extension if this extension is currently not installed this installation
can easily be done through the extensions tab within visual studio code
at the top of the home.js file let's import the hero image from within the
images directory like this let's include an image tag within the JSX code
returned from the home component
then let's open the app.js file let's import the home component into the app
component with this line of code
let's delete the code that we don't need but ensure that we leave the div root
element that contains the class name attribute that references the app.css
class then let's appropriately reference the home element by including the home
tag within the div parent tag like this
let's type npm start to fire up our application
great but the image looks huge and is not displayed appropriately for our hero
image so we are going to use bootstrap to style this hero image so to install
bootstrap type this command at your command prompt and press enter
to have access throughout our application to relevant bootstrap classes
we must include this import statement within the index.js file
now within the root div tag of the home component let's include the class name
attribute and set it to the bootstrap class named container like this let's
run our code
what's happening here is the image is still too large for its container
element so to remedy this let's create a scoped CSS style sheet for the home
component so let's create a file within the home directory named home.css
within the home.css file let's create a reference to the relevant image within
the container div tag like this and let's set the image width to 100% within
the home component let's create a reference to the home.css file with
this line of code
let's type NPM start at the terminal prompt to launch our application
and that is much better great
so that is a great start but we are also going to need some other third-party
packages dependencies in order to integrate certain functionality into our
application for example we want to install the react root to DOM package
that will be instrumental in the global management of our menu and link
functionality our navigation functionality we are going to use the
react player component for displaying videos that denote lessons for our
courses to our users we'll use Axios to manage our client interactions with a
server-side web API component so here we have used bootstraps container class to
house our hero image so that it is appropriately displayed within our home
component as a hero image we can also leverage bootstrap by using components
that reside within the react bootstrap package we will look at using such
components a bit later in this video for now let's install react bootstrap to
install react bootstrap type NPM space I space react dash bootstrap and press the
enter key
great let's install the Axios library we are going to use Axios for making our
HTTP client requests to the relevant server-side endpoints so as to return
the relevant data from the Neo4j database that hosts the relevant
curriculum data that we want to display to our users we'll also use Axios to
implement the enroll functionality ie this is functionality whereby a user can
enroll in a particular course we could use the windows.fetch function which is
available by default within our browsers for this purpose instead of Axios but
Axios provides us with key advantages please navigate to this URL if you'd
like to learn more about these key advantages this link is available below
in the description of this video to install Axios type NPM space install
space Axios and then press the enter key the next packages I would like to
install allow us to leverage font awesome from within our react
applications so at the command prompt please type NPM space I space at
Fort Awesome forward slash react dash font awesome and then press the enter key
let's install one more font awesome related package to do this type NPM
space I space at Fort Awesome forward slash free dash solid dash SVG dash
icons and then press the enter key great we'll look at the details of using the
relevant font dash awesome functionality a little bit later in this video the
next component I want to install is react player this will allow us to play
YouTube videos from within our react application the individual lessons
within the courses in which our user is enrolled will be presented to the user
as videos these videos reside on the YouTube platform so to install react
player type NPM space I space react dash player at the command prompt and then
press the enter key
then let's install react router Dom which allows us to leverage rich
navigation and routing functionality from within our react application to
install react router Dom at your command prompt please type NPM space I space
react dash router Dom and then press the enter key
if we open the package dot JSON file you can see the relevant dependencies that
we have just installed great so let's create the navigation bar that will
appear at the top of our applications UI so this can be referred to as the header
for our application the navigation bar will contain a register and login button
and relevant navigation menu options so let's create a folder within the
components directory named header
please ensure that the H in header used to name our folder is in lowercase let's
create the file for the header component and let's name it header dot JS where
the H is an uppercase so we are going to use font awesome in this component to
display a graduation cap as the logo for our application which will appear in the
top left hand corner of the user's screen so let's write code to import the
relevant font awesome components
then we are going to use react bootstrap for our buttons so let's import the
button component from the react bootstrap package with this line of code
we are going to use the container component for layout purposes let's
import the nav component from react bootstrap which will be used for layout
and styling purposes let's also import the navbar component for the purpose of
styling our navigation display lastly let's import the use navigate hook and
the nav link component from the react rootadom package so that we can leverage
the relevant react rootadom functionality for navigation purposes
let's change this div tag to be a navbar tag within the navbar element let's
include a container element let's include the fluid keyword within the
container element this will ensure that the navigation bar spans the entire
width of the web page rather than placed centrally within the web page let's
reference the navbar dot brand react bootstrap element and set its class name
property to the menu dash link bootstrap class like this then let's include the
graduation cap font awesome icon like this as a child element of the navbar
dot brand element this icon serves as our applications logo let's include the
navbar dot toggle element here which will allow the navigation to be shown
and hidden through a toggle mechanism made available to the user on smaller
screen sizes so as you can see bootstrap is great for responsive layouts so let's
include the nav element and let's style the nav element appropriately
let's include the button component to represent our login button the variant
property is set to info as a style choice let's set the class name property
to a bootstrap class named me-2 this is so that our buttons are spaced
appropriately let's include the register button which will appear to the right of
the login button on our navigation bar and let's style the register button in
the same way that we have styled the login button right let's open the app
dot JS file and firstly make sure that we are importing the header component
into the app component then let's include the header element reference
just above the home tag within the JSX code that will be returned from the app
component let's use npm start to launch the application so that we can view what
our navigation bar currently looks like great okay because our navigation bar is
currently white our brand icon is also white so we can't currently see our
graduation cap brand so let's change the color to red for now
great okay so I want to make the background for our application as black
and address styling features that I'd like to apply to all of our components
one way we can do this is to include the relevant styling code within the app dot
CSS file which is referenced by the app component the app component is the
parent component for all our bespoke child components so the styles included
within the app dot CSS file will propagate to all the app components
child components so let's firstly import the quicksand font from Google through
this line of code we want the quicksand font to be applied for our entire web
application
let's use the star like this to indicate the following CSS properties apply to the
root tag for our single page application so let's first set the border dash
sizing property to border box if you set the box dash sizing property to border
box on elements like this the padding and border values are included in the
width and height properties for the relevant elements let's set the font dash
family property to quicksand
right let's create the styling for the app element let's set the app root
elements background color to black let's set the color for our text to white
let's set the top margin for the app element to 10 pixels
let's launch the app
you
great
okay so let's create the component that will house the registration functionality
this component will contain a form that the user can fill out to register the
user's relevant details with the system including the user's name username and
password the fields on the form will be name username password and confirm
password
we'll incorporate regular expressions into this dialogue for the purpose of
validating each of these fields each of these fields will be validated in real
time ie as the user enters the relevant information into the relevant text box
controls so let's start by creating a folder named register within the
components folder
let's add a file named register.js within the register folder
and let's also create a file named register CSS
let's go to the register component
let's import the use state hook and the use ref hook into our component so the
use state hook is used to track the state of relevant variables when the
state for a particular variable changes reacts detects this and re-renders the
relevant component in the user's browser this use ref hook will be used to
reference a text box form control let's import relevant react bootstrap
components
you
let's import relevant font awesome components
let's use rafce to generate the boilerplate code for our register
component let's declare a constant named name ref which will be used to reference
the name text box control let's use the use state hook to monitor a variable
named name the set name function will be used to change the state of the name
variable the name variable will be bound as it were to the relevant text box
control where the user will enter the user's name let's include a boolean
variable for the purpose of monitoring the valid or invalid state of the text
value entered into the name control by the user let's create two variables that
are used for the same functionality as the previous two variables that we have
created but are applied to the username text box control so when the username
is deemed as valid the valid username variable is set to true conversely when
the username variables value is deemed as invalid the valid username value is
set to false let's do the same for the password or pwd field ie create two
appropriate variables where their state is tracked
let's do the same regarding the confirm password field which is used to validate
if the confirm password field matches the password field
so I've already prepared the regular expressions for the relevant fields off
screen please feel free to copy the relevant regular expressions from this
location on github
so let's set a constant to the regular expression that will be used for
validating the name field please remember if you get stuck or you wish to
copy and paste the code rather than following along with creating the code
line by line with me you are able to copy the relevant code from a github
repository available at this location so this regular expression will ensure that
the name field has at least two characters and no numbers are included
so let's include the regular expression for the username field the validation
criterion for this regular expression means that the username must be between
8 to 20 characters long no underscore or period characters are
included at the beginning no double underscore or underscore period
characters or period underscore characters or dot dot characters are
included within the field and no underscore or dot characters appear at
the end of the word
so this regular expression is used for the password field this regular
expression means that in order for the password field to be deemed as valid a
minimum of eight characters must be included the password must include at
least one letter one number and one special character so let's apply the use
effect hook so that a function that we'll write that is passed as an
argument to the use effect hook is fired when the register component first loads
so the use effect hook accepts two arguments the first argument is the
function to be fired and the second argument determines when the function is
fired so we want the function passed in as the first argument to be fired when
the register component is first loaded so we can achieve this by passing in
empty square brackets as an argument to the second parameter of the use effect
hook so we want the name control to receive focus when the register
component first loads we can achieve this with this line of code we'll write
the code to create the relevant form controls including the name control in
just a bit and this will of course be implemented within the JSX section of
this component let's use the use effect hook to monitor the state of the name
variable which will be changed with every key press that the user makes
within the name text box which as I've said will be created soon so to do this
we pass a function as the first arguments to the use effect hook that we
want fired when the state of the name variable changes then in order to tell
react as it were that we only want the relevant function to fire when the name
variable state changes we can pass the name variable within square brackets as
the second arguments to the use effect hook
note that the test method is executed on the relevant regular expression to
ascertain whether or not the name entered by the user is valid or not the
result returned from this line of code will either be true or false
we can then set the state of the valid name boolean variable to the result
returned from the test function we'll create UI functionality to show that the
name field is valid or invalid in just a bit so we are providing the user with
real-time validation feedback as the user types the user's name into the name
field then let's apply another use effect hook to perform similar
functionality for the user name
let's apply another use effect hook to check that the password is valid or
invalid based on the relevant regular expression
then we must also check whether the password field matches the confirm
password field note that within the array passed in as an arguments to the
second parameter of the use effect hook is the variable representing the
password field and the variable representing the confirm password field
so this means that each time the password or confirm password fields
change the relevant validation functionality is executed we'll wire up
the relevant variables to their counterpart text box form controls in
just a bit you'll see that the on change event of the relevant form controls is
used for this purpose right so let's create the JSX code within the relevant
section of the register component let's create a container component
let's create an appropriate heading
let's create a main element and a div element within the main element please
include the relevant class name attributes and values within the
relevant elements let's include the react bootstrap form element so each text box
control will reside within a form dot group element which will also include a
label control so let's create the relevant code for the name text box control
the form dot label element contains a span element here we have a ternary
operator that shows all hides either a font awesome times icon or a tick icon
based on whether the valid name variable is true or false so this span element
will be shown to the user based on whether the span elements class name
property references the CSS class named valid or the CSS class named hide we'll
create these CSS classes in just a bit so if the valid name value is true the
FA check icon is displayed next to the name text box control conversely if the
valid name variable is set to false this span element is displayed to the user
which means the FA times or a cross icon is displayed to the user indicating that
what the user has entered into the name field is currently invalid then let's
create the text box control for the name field like this
note that we are setting the ref property to the name ref const this
allows us to reference the text box within the relevant use effect hook
where we have created code so that the name text box is given focus when the
register component first loads then the on change event is wired up to an arrow
function that sets the tracked name variable every time the user changes the
text entered within the name text box let's create the form control code for
the username field which contains similar functionality
let's create the form control code for the password field
and the confirm password field
let's create the code for a submit button so we want to disable this submit
button while any of the relevant form fields are not valid so let's set the
relevant disabled property to this boolean expression
so before we test the validation code for our register form let's set up the
roots for our application so that we can navigate to the register component
through the navigation bar that has been created within our header component so
let's open the app.js file let's import the roots component and the root
component from within the React router DOM package let's include the roots
element below the header element we want the header element to appear regardless
of where the user navigates to within our application so we need the header
appropriately displayed outside the roots element
within the roots element let's include the relevant roots where we can tell
React router DOM as it were about the paths of our components
we haven't yet created the layout component so let's do that now the
layout component provides instructions to react as it were regarding the
overall layout of the relevant components that are mapped to relevant
roots
let's import the layout component
we also need to create a root for the app component and we must do this within
the index.js file
we need to wrap this route within the browser router component as well as the
roots component like this
let's go back to the header component and create code so that when the register
button is clicked that the register component is appropriately loaded let's
create a const named navigate that is assigned a function returned from the
use navigate hook let's create a reusable function named handle nav
let's use the navigate function to navigate the user to a path passed in to
the handle nav function let's pass in the relevant path to the register
components to the handle nav function so when the register button is clicked the
register component is loaded
let's test the code
okay so to fix this issue we need to correct a typo here where we have
incorrectly named the regular expression const pertaining to the username field
great but in order for our validation to work as expected we need to create the
relevant CSS classes let's make sure that we import the register.css file into
the register component let's open the register.css file and create the code
for the relevant CSS classes let's create the CSS code for the register
dash container class which will make sure the layout for the register dialog is
appropriate we are using the flexgrid functionality to appropriately handle
the layout let's include the register dash layout class to handle the layout
for the register form
let's include the valid class so that the elements referencing this class are
appropriately displayed
let's include the hide class so the elements referencing this class are
appropriately hidden
let's include a class named invalid dash icon to display the times or cross
font awesome icon in red let's include a class named valid dash icon to display
the checked icon or tick font awesome icon in green let's include a class
named register dash message which will style a displayed message to the user
that is centrally aligned and in white text the appropriate text will display
once a user has successfully registered
let's test the UI validation functionality for the name field
let's test the UI validation functionality for the user name field
okay so we have an issue the name field is also being affected this should not
be happening let's look at the code
okay so within this user fact hook lies the problem we are currently using
the set valid name function here whereas we should of course be using the set
valid user name function here so let's fix this
great let's test the password field and the confirm password field validation
functionality oops and of course the password control should be of type
password and not text
we must of course also make the same fix for the confirm password control
excellent so let's go back to the register CSS file and make sure our
register form is responsive on smaller screen sizes so let's use an
appropriate media query for this purpose
excellent so now we want to interface with the Neo4j database hosted in the
cloud so we are going to download the code for the HTTP based web API
component written in Java to our local machine so we are going to host the web
API component on our local machines just to make the development of our
application a bit easier this web API component is hosted using spring boot in
order to be able to run this code locally on a Windows computer you must
ensure that you have the Java JDK installed on your local machine if you
don't yet have the Java JDK installed please navigate to this URL then follow
the instructions for installing the Java JDK Java JDK version 20 or version 17
should be fine the next step is to clone the GitHub repository at this URL onto
your local machine this GitHub repository contains the Java code for the relevant
web API so we are hosting the server-side code on our local machines
we are connecting to a Neo4j database hosted in the cloud from our local
machines please remember the local directory that contains the cloned GitHub
repository code we need to run a command at the command line later on to run the
relevant web API component as stated before this will be run locally
please ensure that you have configured the web API component correctly to point
to the Neo4j database that you have created if you are unsure of how to do
this please follow the relevant instructions provided in the previous
part of this course the values I'm showing you here will of course not
apply to your particular environment
for now let's create the client-side react code to connect to the locally
hosted web API component so let's create a folder within the SRC folder named API
within the API folder let's create a file named axios-config.js
let's first write code for importing axios let's create the code to set up
the axios-client component
so let's add the base URL property and set it to localhost port 8080 which is
where we will be able to connect to the relevant web API endpoints this web API
component of course handles calls to the relevant Neo4j database that is hosted
in the cloud let's create appropriate code for the headers property
now let's go to the register component and import the axios-client component
let's create a JavaScript function named post data we must include the E dot
prevent default line of code for when submitting a form from within a react
component because we'll be using the on submit event for the submission of the
register form then let's create an object that encapsulates the data entered
by the user I'm going to hard code the roles value here which is okay for demo
purposes but you'd want to handle this field more appropriately for a
production environment for example you could have a list of roles presented to
the user in a list box control and the user can select the relevant role from
the list box control right so we can write code for post requests using the
axios-client component like this so we are simply posting the object we have
just created to an appropriate endpoint created for handling the register post
request we can include basic error handling code through the use of try
catch code and we can output an appropriate message to the user
regarding whether the user has been registered successfully or not let's
include code at the bottom of the form to display this registration status
information let's first set the submit success message appropriately based on
the response returned from the server side code and at the bottom of the
register form let's write the code to display the relevant message saved
within the submit success variable
so let's set the min height property of the app parent component so that it
extends to the bottom of the web page and we can do this by setting the min
height property here so that its minimum height is 100 VH so the result of this
is that the background color will be black regardless of which component is
loaded because the relevant components are all child components of the app
parent component and of course we must wire up the on submit event to an
appropriate event handler so we are wiring up the on submit event to the
post data method within the form element like this okay so to run the web API
component on your computer you can run this command at your command prompt so
launch the command prompt as administrator change the current
directory to the root directory of where you cloned the relevant Java code
locally just a reminder the relevance Java code can be found at this location
on github so once you have done that type this command at your command prompt
and press enter after you press the enter key you should see similar
information to the information displayed on my screen logged to your screen
let's run the react code and see if we can register a user
oops we have a bug here
we are referencing a control named PWD with the object that we are attempting
to post
the PWD field doesn't exist because we named the relevant field password so
let's fix this
we have successfully registered a user so we are now successfully communicating
from the react client code with the Java server-side code which for development
purposes we are currently hosting on our local machines so we have successfully
registered a user the next logical step is to create the login functionality
let's create a folder named login and let's ensure that the first character
is lowercase within the login folder let's create a file named login.js and
let's ensure that the first character of the file name is an uppercase let's
create the file within the login folder named login.css
right let's write the code for the login component let's reference the
login.css file let's import the relevant dependencies
let's import the use state, use effect and use ref hooks from react let's
import the container component from the react bootstrap package
let's import the button component from the react bootstrap package
let's import the form component from the react bootstrap package
let's appropriately import the axios client component
let's import the use navigate hook the link component and the use location hook
from react root to DOM
let's create the boilerplate code for our component by appropriately typing
rafce and pressing the enter key
great let's create a const named navigate and assign it a value returned
from the use navigate hook
we will be able to use the function assigned to the navigate const in code
for navigation purposes
let's assign a value returned from the use ref hook to the user ref const
this will allow us to reference a specific form control within a function
we'll look at this functionality in just a bit in order to track the state of the
username let's use the use state hook for this purpose so user is a variable
we want tracked by react and we must use the set user function to change the
state of the user variable let's use the use state hook to track the state of the
entered password
let's use the use effect hook so that a function executes when the login
component first loads the code for this function simply sets the username field
to have the focus and this happens when the login component is first loaded
let's create the UI code for our login component within the JSX section of our
component so let's first reference the react bootstrap container component so
that our login form is housed as it were within an element that references the
container bootstrap style let's create a heading for our login form
for styling purposes let's create a main element and within that a div
element within these elements our references to appropriate CSS classes
we will create the code for these CSS classes in just a bit so like with the
registration dialog we create a form element and within the form element the
relevant form controls within form dot group elements these components are
imported from the react bootstrap package and we are using them for layout
and styling purposes so each of the form groups contain a label and a text box so
we have the username field and the password field within the login form
note how we are using the on change event to change the state of relevant
variables as the user changes the text within the relevant text box controls
let's reference the button component and this button will serve as the login
forms submit button please remember if you get lost at any point while
following along the full code is available at this location on github the
link to this github repository is available in the description of this
video
let's create an arrow function to handle the submit functionality
so let's use this code to reference the values that the user has entered into
the username field and the password field
let's implement basic exception handling through the use of try catch
functionality basic authentication has been implemented in the web API
component please navigate to this URL if you'd like to learn more about basic
authentication so in terms of basic authentication we must encode the
username and password values in a particular format before we submit a
particular HTTP request to the server-side code in order to implement
basic authentication on the client we are going to pass the username and
password in a particular format through the header of a HTTP GET request for
this particular login component the relevant format for the username and
password is username colon password
this is essential for basic authentication we must also encode the
username colon password value in base 64 encoding we can use JavaScript's BTOA
function for this purpose so let's create a const named B64 encode and
assign it the value of username colon password that is base 64 encoded using
the BTOA JavaScript function the next step is to create an object representing
the header information that will be passed to the relevant web API endpoint
so let's create a const named config and set it to an object to represent
appropriate HTTP header information this object contains a property named headers
which is set to an object with a property named authorization the
authorization property is set to the text value basic followed by a space
followed by the base 64 encoded username colon password text value note we are
wrapping the value assigned to the authorization property in backtick
characters so that we can interpolate the relevant text value this means we can
include a variable within the backtick characters by wrapping the variable
within curly brackets and preceding the curly brackets with the dollar symbol
let's create a request to the relevant endpoint using axios note we are
passing in the username and password through a HTTP GET request made to the
relevant endpoint through the config object the config object contains the
authentication details for the user which is appropriately added to the
header of the relevant HTTP GET request
so before we test the login functionality let's make sure that an
appropriate route is set up for the login component so let's open the app
dot JS file and include the code for the relevant route let's import the login
component into the app component and include code that represents the route
for the login component
let's open the header dot JS file and include navigation functionality in this
component so that the user can navigate to the login component by clicking the
login button displayed on the navigation bar
let's test the code
we have a few issues here so let's fix these issues please see the relevant
GitHub code at this location if you get stuck on any issues
this is the main issue here this should be used state and not use ref
there are also a few other issues that need to be fixed so let's fix these
issues
let's run the code
so we have our login form presented to the user but it doesn't look great
we'll fix this in just a bit so off screen I registered a user named Henry
Jameson please feel free to register your own users while testing I'm going
to test the login functionality using Henry Jameson's credentials I'm going to
use a simple JavaScript alert to ensure that the HTTP status sent back from the
relevant endpoint is 200 meaning that the HTTP request has been successfully
processed on the server
excellent we have received a response with a status code of 200 so we've
received a HTTP response with a status code of 200 meaning success so next
let's style the login screen appropriately let's open the login dot
CSS file let's style the CSS class named login dash container
we are using the flex grid for styling and layout purposes the flex grid is
great for creating responsive UI code for various screen sizes let's create
the login dash layout CSS class we are also using the flex grid functionality
here note that we are setting the flex direction property to column which means
the relevant elements will stack one on top of the other in a column layout by
default if the flex direction property is not set this setting defaults to row
this means the relevant elements are presented one next to the other in a row
layout let's give each of these form dot group elements suitable margin bottom
settings using bootstrap so that we are creating appropriate spacing between the
form groups so that our layout here is a bit neater
great
let's include an error message at the bottom of our form for if something goes
wrong during the authentication process
so let's set the state of an appropriate error message based on the response
provided by the server so if a status code of 200 is returned from the server
the state of the error message variable can be set to an empty string or if the
status code does not indicate success or an error is thrown we can set the error
message variable appropriately to indicate that the login has failed on
the server if an exception is thrown we can include the error message that has
been caught within the try catch block then let's output the value stored in
the error message variable to the screen at the bottom of the login form
you
let's dial the error message display appropriately
so to test this I'm going to force a 404 exception meaning that the relevant
endpoint is not found by changing the endpoint path to something that is
incorrect great lastly let's ensure that our login form looks good on smaller
screens so to do this within the login CSS file let's include appropriate media
query functionality
you
let's include code here to automatically navigate the user to the home page once
the user has successfully logged in
excellent great so once the user has been authenticated we want our other
components to know as it were that the user is logged into the system so the
best way to do this is through the use of context react context is a way to
manage state globally so very basically we use react context so that other
components will be able to retrieve a value from a global store and assess
whether a user is logged into the system or not logged into the system for more
information about react context please navigate to this URL so in order to
create context let's create a folder named context within the SRC folder
within the context folder let's create a file named auth provider.js let's
import the create context function and the use state hook from react let's set
a const named auth context to a value returned from the create context method
like this note that we are passing an empty object to the create context
function let's write code to export a component named auth provider note that
this code simply means that the auth variable and set auth function will be
passed down to all components that are wrapped by the auth provider component
so this makes these accessible to the relevant child components that are wrapped
by the auth provider parent component we'll look at this in just a bit so what
this means is that all relevant components will be able to access the
auth variable within all relevant child components if the auth variable is not
null this means that the relevant user has been authenticated ie logged onto
the system of course the state of the auth variable is managed through the
use of the use state hook implemented within the auth provider component
let's create a folder named hooks within the SRC folder within the hooks folder
let's create a hook named use auth this code basically allows relevant
components to access the auth context which means access is provided to the
auth variable and the set auth function the set auth function of course is used
for changing the state of the auth variable so to log in you change the
state of the auth variable and to log out you appropriately change the state
of the auth variable by setting it to null the auth variable state indicates
whether the user is logged into the system and the set auth function can be
used to change the state of the auth variable so the set auth function can
essentially be used to log the user into the system or out of the system let's
Let's create a hook named Use Axios Private.
So the code for the hook is created so that the client code can retrieve an appropriate
Axios client object that automatically includes an appropriate HTTP header containing the
logged-on user's credentials.
These credentials are appropriately formatted for basic authentication.
So the returned Axios client object from this hook must be used for accessing protected
resources on the server, i.e. retrieved through the relevant API endpoints.
These protected resources require basic authentication to be performed before returning relevant
data to the client.
Now the code here creates what's known as an interceptor, so if the Use Axios Private
hook is used from within client code to reference the Axios client, the login credentials are
automatically injected into the header of the relevant HTTP request.
So this means that the client code doesn't need to inject this authentication header
information every time a HTTP request is made to an endpoint.
This interceptor code does this automatically.
Just a reminder, if you get stuck creating this code, please reference the relevant code
at this GitHub repository location.
So, the next step is to open the index.js file and wrap all the relevant components
within the auth provider parent component.
As discussed, this allows the child components, or makes provisions for the child components,
to easily access the auth variable so that the relevant component can access whether
the user is logged into the system or not logged into the system.
So let's look at how this works.
Let's open the home.js file.
Let's import the use auth hook.
Let's use the use auth hook to return the auth variable and the set auth function from
the relevant context global store.
Now within the UI.jsx code section of the home component, we can check the auth variable
to see if the user is logged into the system, like this.
So if the user is logged into the system, the code displays a message on the screen.
You are logged in.
If the user is not logged into the system, the code displays the hero image to the screen.
So let's open the login.js file and use the use auth hook to return the set auth function
from the context.
Let's use the set auth function to assign an appropriate object to the auth variable.
This object contains the username and password.
So once the user is successfully authenticated, an object containing the user's username
and password is passed into the set auth function, which effectively changes the state of the
auth variable, which indicates, of course, that the user is logged into the system.
So you can see that now this global context can be used to retrieve the username and password
from this object, ie the object that we have just passed in to the set auth function to
change the state of the auth variable.
The username and password can now be injected into the header of HTTP requests through the
interceptor functionality that we have implemented in the use Axios private hook.
Let's run the code.
Let's register a new user named Brandon Lowe.
Okay, the password here is password one exclamation mark.
Let's then log into the system.
Excellent.
So let's create our logout functionality within the header component.
Let's retrieve the auth variable and the set auth function from the use auth hook.
So if the auth dot user property is not null, this means that the user is logged into the
system.
So we want a logout button to be displayed in the navigation bar rather than the login
and registration buttons.
When a user is logged into the system, we only want the login and registration buttons presented
to the user when the user is not logged into the system.
Let's create a function for when the logout button is clicked.
So let's create this logout function.
Within this function, we can simply set the auth variable to null by using the set auth
function for this purpose.
This effectively means that the user is now logged out of the system.
Then let's also implement code to navigate the user to the home component.
Right, let's log into the system.
Great.
Let's log out of the system.
Excellent.
So let's create the code within the home component so that when the user is authenticated, a
list of courses is displayed to the user rather than the hero image.
Let's create code using the use state hook so that React monitors the state of a variable
named course data.
We can change the state of the course data variable using the set course data function
returned from the use state hook.
Let's use the use Axios private hook to return a reference to the Axios client that we are
going to use to request a list of courses from the server.
Note, we are getting a reference to the Axios client using the use Axios private hook.
Because the use Axios private hook contains functionality that will automatically inject
the logged on user's credentials into the header of the relevant HTTP request.
So each request to the server requires the user's credentials so that basic authentication
can be appropriately performed.
This is because the course data is a protected resource.
So the user must be authenticated before this course information is passed from server to
client.
Remember, implemented within the use Axios private hook is interceptor functionality.
So the HTTP request is intercepted and the relevant authentication information is injected
into the header of the HTTP request before the relevant HTTP request is made to the server.
So let's create a JavaScript arrow function named fetch courses.
So here a get request is made.
And once the results are returned, we are using the set course data function to appropriately
change the state of the course data variable.
This results in the home component re-rendering, which means a list of courses will be displayed
on the UI once the data becomes available and the set course data function is appropriately
called to change the state of the course data variable.
We'll implement the code for displaying the course data on the UI in just a bit.
Let's use the use a fet hook to call the fetch data function when the home component first
loads.
But we only want the fetch data function to be called if the user is logged into the system.
Let's display the course data value in an alert to test our HTTP GET request.
Let's run the code.
Oops, we currently are not importing the use state hook.
Let's fix this.
We now have a 404 error.
This is occurring because we need to include a forward slash at the end of the endpoint
path here.
Let's try again.
And we are getting the expected JSON results with a now alert.
This means our HTTP request is working as expected.
Right, so let's write the code for displaying the course data on the UI.
So in the return section of the home component, let's implement the code for displaying the
course data.
I'm going to create this code fairly quickly with minimal explanation.
So we are using the map function here to iterate through the courses list returned from the
server.
This courses list is stored within the course data variable.
So I'm deliberately not providing a lot of explanation here.
Please note that this part of the course is not a detailed guide on Bootstrap or even
React for that matter.
This part of the course has been created for the purpose of placing the advantages provided
through the use of the Neo4j graph database management system in the context of a web-based
application.
Please feel free to copy the relevant code from GitHub.
The first map function, let's refer to this as the parent map function, traverses the
list of courses.
Note that we are outputting the title for each course within the parent map function.
This title property will be returned from the relevant endpoint.
Within the parent map function, another map function is implemented that traverses a list
of lessons.
The lessons make up the relevant course.
So we are outputting the title of the course as a heading.
A list of lessons is outputted for each of the relevant courses underneath the relevant
heading.
So essentially the data is grouped by course.
The title for each course and the course's lessons are outputted to the UI.
Bootstrap is being used for layout and styling purposes.
Note that we are setting the key property for this element to the identifier property
for each course.
When using the map function, it is always a good idea to appropriately set the React
key property for the relevant element like this.
This helps React to be more efficient when considering the component.
We are also appropriately setting the key property for the element here related to each
lesson.
We are setting the key property here to the identifier of each lesson.
Let's test the code.
Okay, we have an issue here.
So to fix this issue, we need to import the link component from the React Rooted DOM package.
We are using the link component to wrap the title for each course.
This is because we are going to create a component responsible for displaying course details
for each individual course in a bit.
Once this is done, we will point this link to the relevant course component, where the
details for the relevant individual course will be outputted.
This will allow a user to click the header for a course and for the course details for
the relevant course to be displayed after the user clicks the relevant link on the homepage.
You can see we have four courses currently saved to the system.
So let's create a component that displays the course details for a particular course.
So from a UX user experience perspective, the user will click on the course heading
on the homepage and will be navigated to a component that displays the course details
for the relevant course.
Let's create a folder named course and a file within the course folder named course.js.
Let's generate the boilerplate code for the course component.
Let's open the app.js file and include an appropriate route for our course component.
Note that this component accepts a parameter passed into the course component, which is
an identifier for a particular course.
So to tell the React router DOM system as it were about the relevant identifier parameter,
we can include a colon followed by the name of the parameter, identifier, at the end of
the relevant route path, like this.
Let's go back to the course.js file.
Let's include the relevant imports.
I'm not going to explain this import code as we have already covered this while creating
code for the other components, all except for the use params hook.
We are going to use the use params hook to extract a parameter value that will be passed
into this component from the home component when a user clicks on a course heading.
So let's create a value from the use params hook.
We can then use the params object to retrieve the name of the parameter that we named identifier.
Let's create a tracked variable named course data.
We can use the set course data function to change the state of the course data variable.
Of course, when the state of the variable returned from the use state hook is changed,
this results in the relevant component being re-rendered.
Let's use the use Axios private hook to get a reference to the Axios client where an interceptor
is employed to inject the user's authentication details into the HTTP header for any HTTP
request made using the Axios client returned from the use Axios private hook.
Let's use the use effect hook so that we can execute code that retrieves data for the relevant
course when the course component first loads.
Let's use an alert to output the results returned from the relevant get request.
Within the home.js file, let's include the appropriate path to the course component within
the relevant link component like this.
Note we are including the course identifier as part of the path assigned to the to property
of the link element.
Let's test the code.
Great, the results are outputted through a JavaScript alert.
The JavaScript alert is of course just used for testing purposes.
Let's create the UI code in the part of the course component that returns JSX code.
So the code is very similar to the code within the JSX section of the home component.
So to speed things up, I'm just going to copy and paste the relevant code from the home
component into the course component.
And let's adapt the code appropriately for the course component.
So the difference between the relevant code in the home component and the relevant code
in the course component is that only one specific course is displayed in the course component,
whereas a list of all courses are outputted from the home component.
Just a reminder, if you get lost while creating the code for any part of this application,
please reference the code that can be found at this location on GitHub.
Note that for our course component, we are also including the instructor that teaches
the relevant course.
This data is returned from the server in the teacher property.
So the course component only ever returns one course rather than a list of courses that
are displayed within the home component.
So we copy this code from the home component, which is currently incorrect for the course
component.
We need to replace the D variable here with course data because the D references an item
in a list of courses in the home component.
This course data variable represents one particular course.
Excellent.
The next component that I want to create is used for the purpose of displaying only the
list of courses in which the logged on user is enrolled.
So let's create a folder within the components folder named enrolled courses.
Within the enrolled courses folder, let's create a JavaScript file named enrolled courses.js.
Let's copy and paste the relevant imports from the home component.
So for this component, I'm going to copy most of the code from the home component as the
code is very similar.
The only difference is that we are calling a different endpoint on the server to get
the relevant course data.
In this case, only a list of courses in which the logged on user is enrolled will be displayed
to the user.
Just a reminder, you can of course get the finished code from the relevant GitHub repository.
Let's include an appropriate root component for the enrolled courses component within
the app.js file like this.
Now let's open the header.js file and include code so that a link to the home component
and the enrolled courses component will appear within the navigation bar at the top of the UI.
In order for our links to be displayed in white text, let's include the following properties
within the navbar element like this.
So on smaller screens, this navigation bar doesn't currently look very good.
So let's wrap the relevant navigation elements within the nav collapse element so that on
smaller screens the navigation bar responds appropriately.
Great!
We copy this code from the home component and we of course don't need this code that
outputs the hero image in the enrolled courses component.
So let's delete this code here.
Currently, when we click on the enrolled courses link, no data is displayed.
And this is an expected result because the logged on user has not enrolled in any courses.
So let's create the functionality so that a user can enroll in courses.
We'll implement this functionality from within the course component.
So let's create code that displays a button within the course component that is labeled
enroll.
This button must only display if the enrolled property for a particular course object returns
false, which denotes that the logged on user is not currently enrolled in the relevant
course.
So when this button is clicked, we want a function named enroll to be executed.
The code for this enroll function will of course enroll the logged on user into the
relevant course.
So let's create the enroll function.
You can see that we are using a HTTP POST request to post the course identifier wrapped
in an object to a specific endpoint.
The server side functionality written in Java interacts with the Neo4j database management
system appropriately in order to create the appropriate relationship between the user
and the relevant course.
So if the endpoint returns a status response of 200, meaning success, let's display this
message to the user, which simply thanks the user for enrolling in the chosen course.
And let's include codes to navigate the user to the enrolled courses component.
Let's test this functionality.
So each of the lessons listed for the enrolled courses must have a play button icon next
to it.
When the user clicks the play button icon, the lesson that has been created as a YouTube
video will be displayed to the user through the video component that we are about to create.
So the play button is implemented using the fund awesome icon component.
The
font awesome icon element is wrapped by the link element, the link elements to property
is set to the path of the video component that we will create.
The lessons identifier is passed in as a parameter to the video component.
When the relevant video link is clicked, the play button icon denotes this link on the
front end.
So in the home component, we are currently handling what to output to the screen, the
hero image is displayed when the user is not logged into the system, and a list of courses
is displayed when the user is logged into the system.
When the user clicks the enrolled courses link, this is currently not being handled
appropriately.
We want the login screen presented to the user if the enrolled courses link is clicked,
while the user is not logged into the system, then when the user logs into the system, we
want the user to be navigated to the enrolled courses component rather than the home component.
So let's implement the code to handle this scenario.
Let's first create a component within the components folder named required auth.
This component is responsible for navigating the user to the login screen if auth is null,
i.e. the user is not logged into the system.
And let's open the app.js file and wrap the enrolled courses route with the required auth
element like this.
So the user will not be able to access the enrolled courses component unless the user
is logged into the system.
If the user tries to click the relevant link, the user will be presented with the login
screen so this forces the user to log in in order to see the user's enrolled courses.
And once the user logs in, the user is navigated directly to the enrolled courses component,
which means the user can see the list of courses in which the user has been enrolled.
Within the login component, we need to create the navigation code so that when the user
logs in, the user is navigated to the component that the user tried to access prior to being
redirected to the login screen.
In this particular case, this would be the enrolled courses component.
Let's test this code, great!
So the last component that I want to create is of course the video component.
This component uses the react player component to play the lessons that have been created
as videos on YouTube to the user.
Let's create a folder named video.
Let's create a file within this folder named video.js.
And let's create another file within the video folder named video.css.
The code for implementing the play video functionality is very basic.
Let's use the use param hook so that we can retrieve the YouTube video ID that will be
passed into the component, like this.
Let's open the app.js file and include the appropriate route so that the react router
DOM system as it were knows how to navigate the user to the video component as well as
pass in the appropriate parameter to the video component.
The parameter value will be the YouTube video ID pertaining to the relevant lesson.
This includes the react player element appropriately within the video component so that the relevant
YouTube video plays immediately.
We are setting the playing property to true for the react player element for this purpose.
Then let's set the URL property appropriately to point to the relevant video on YouTube.
Note that the URL includes the YouTube ID that is passed in as a parameter to this component.
Let's style the video component appropriately.
In fact, let's test the code.
I'd like to introduce you to this exciting new Unity for Beginners course, where we'll
create a game using Unity and C sharp over a series of videos.
All the software that we'll use including Unity and VS Code can be downloaded free of
charge.
This course is totally free.
Hi and welcome.
I'm Gavin Lon.
The rigid body component allows us to apply physics to a game object, for example gravity.
But we are going to write code in the update method to apply a forward force to the player
game object in response to the user pressing down.
The W key on the user's keyboard.
So to improve the user's experience, you can include a spinner that appears to the user
while data is being loaded.
So in fact, the last component that we'll create could be the spinner component.
So when the data is loading, we present the user with a spinner.
And then when the relevant data becomes available, the spinner component disappears and the data
is displayed to the user.
So for this purpose, I've created a spinner component.
Please reference the relevant code on GitHub if you'd like to include this spinner functionality
within your application.
I'm going to fast forward the creation of the spinner component, as this is purely a
bonus piece of code that you can study at your own pace if you are interested.
To implement the spinner, we are simply creating a React component, relevant CSS code to style
and animate the spinner.
And functionality within the relevant components to appropriately show and hide the spinner.
The showing and hiding of the spinner is implemented using a boolean variable, where the state
of the relevant variable is tracked through the use of the use state hook from within
the relevant components showing or hiding the spinner.
Please review the code in detail at the relevant GitHub repository location.
The link to the relevant repository is available below in the description of this video.
We can pass in the relevant boolean value as a prop to the spinner component to indicate
to the spinner component to be visible or hidden, like this.
Let's integrate the spinner component into the enrolled courses component.
Thank you.
you
Hi and welcome! I'm Gavin Lawn.
This is part two in a course where we'll create a game using C-sharp in Unity.
In part one, I demonstrated the...
...actually making the game, at runtime, more robust.
For details on C-sharp data types, I've included a link to a C-sharp tutorial on C-sharp data.
So, I'm going to finish the code for this application by styling the header of the courses displayed in the home component.
The course component and the enrolled courses component.
I'm including the relevant CSS classes within the app.css file, so that the classes affect all of these components.
I know the UI for this application is not beautiful.
But the purpose of this part of the course is to place an application that takes advantage of a Neo4j graph database management system
for the purpose of managing relationships between data entities in the context of a web-based application.
My challenge to you is to fork the GitHub repository that contains the code that I've demonstrated in this part of the course
and abstract the common parts of the JSX code contained in the home component, the course component and the enrolled courses component
into relevant child components.
One suggestion is to create a reusable child component for an individual course.
You can then use appropriate props to dynamically customize the new child course component based on its context, i.e. its parent component.
For example, in the enrolled courses component, a play button appears next to every lesson for each course.
Whereas in the home component, these play buttons are not included next to any of the lessons for each course.
So the new course child component will need to account for these two scenarios and dynamically output the appropriate JSX code.
I hope that you've enjoyed this part of the course and have learned a little bit about creating a client react application
that interfaces with a web API component through Axios where basic authentication is employed.
Thank you and take care.